day three of the us chess championship
an epic event in a storybook month of
brilliant chess
america's top grand masters were out for
blood as most of the field were
desperate to preserve their chance
for a shot at the title the teenager
jeffrey zhang defended heroically
against wesley so
in a key matchup of players with seven
points out of eight
but it was wesley who won in the end to
take a full point lead
with just two rounds to go it's time for
the final champion of 2020 to be crowned
the last day of exciting action coming
up next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2020 us chess
championships i'm jennifer shahadi
with yasser sarwan and maurice ashley as
today we crown a champ
yes we do jen hello everyone a great
pleasure for you all to be with us thank
you for joining us
we the tournament has been riveting
and it's the sparkling play of wesley so
that has kept us on our edge of our
seats maurice
i'm just anxious to get into the game so
i'll make it
brief what are you wesley absolutely has
been great but you've seen
raven robson and jeffrey zhang just
punch their way
each and every game and stay in this one
it's a fantastic finish right down to
the end
listen under our standings jen yes we
have wesley so at the top of the
leaderboard with eight points out of
nine
what a score but jeffrey jong and ray
robson
also with fantastic scores that would
usually be clear first as
absolutely it's been it's been
astounding
and uh what's our format jen well our
format
is a 12 player round robin so we have
two more rounds to go
there will be a tie break if we have two
players
at the end at the top of the cross table
and let's take a look at how that
playoff will go
it will be for that forty thousand
dollar top prize
they'll start off by playing a two game
rapid match game ten with a two second
increment
if that's tied they go to armageddon if
we have three players tied
we have a similar format rapid chess
round robin followed by a series of
armageddon
and blitz games
and we're gonna go to maurice to talk to
us a little bit about how today is gonna
look
i mean it has been crazy when have we
last seen
a scoreboard that looks like this one
three
players virtually lapping the rest of
the field
how is it even possible that we're
talking about it in this way
as you see these magnificent scores
eight from wesley out of nine seven out
of nine from ray and jeffrey
those are gangster scores the rest of
the field just
way off in the distance but how did
these players how are these players
going to fair now
coming up in these last two critical
rounds
and ray robson he's just played
brilliant chess some of his games are
just
boss you've got to check those wins out
he gets to try
to knock wesley off his perch right now
if he can do so
he'll have linderman in the last round
but not doing so well at the moment
jeffrey jean on the other hand can only
sit and watch from the outside
he's got to get his job done that's it
play lenderman who
looks to be featuring highly in the
result of the top
and ramirez alejandro not doing well
either so jeffrey just has to try to go
2-0 and hope that the
bound the balls bounce his way but
somebody who doesn't have to worry about
anyone else has his destiny in his hands
his wesley soul he's sitting pretty a
point lead he knows
ray is going to come after him like
gangbusters no question about it
he's got a stop ray at the door and then
hope nakamura is disinterested
and doesn't want to try anything he will
have white in that game so he'll have
a positive vibe as he gets into that
situation but it's this round
right now that matters and he knows
ray's not going for a draw this
tournament has all
been about when win win baby look at the
draw rate
only 39 that's the lowest draw rate
since 1966
66 incredible and last year by
comparison
it was actually a 59
draw rate showing indeed that this
tournament has
been belligerent the players have
gone for the swung for the fences it's
been incredible
will we see more of the same i think so
in these last two games guys
this is it we're gonna have some fun
calling this
amazing finish looking forward to the
donny brook about to begin
and let's take a look at the pairings
jen for round 10.
well we've got two big games as we
narrow down our
field of potential champions jeffrey
zhang
and alex lenderman while ray robson
plays
wesley so big battles there jeffrey
gonna look to go 2-0
ray gonna need to beat so for his chance
at the crown
and round 11 is also going to determine
our champion
a championship round as we see wesley so
fight off against hikaru nakamura one
would have imagined that game
would decide the champion but nakamura
is not in it but he can still be a
spoiler
while ray robson and jeffrey jean are
most likely going to need to try and win
with black and uh
break down the money first once more
chen
well it's 40k for first place and 25 and
16
for second and third respectively those
three prizes are all locked up
but there's something to play for at
every place
every prize is differentiated so big
money at stake in the games today and a
big thank you to
the sink fields and the st louis chess
club for their generosity thank you
everyone involved that's second and
third place by the way
25 versus 18.
or is it 16 25 versus 16. that's nine
grand
even if you don't win it ray and jeffrey
who were locked up
at least second and third you gotta be
thinking that's a nine grand
swing i'm talking about big big deal and
we see the picks here
you guys still have pics in it my guy
nakamura
who would have thought he'd be
languishing at
fifty percent not me anymore not me i
thought it was great
i feel for you maurice only var
myself and jen have shown real
understanding but okay
next time huh robson actually excuse me
you haven't won one this whole
championship so i already won my big
arena did win so i just
joined the crowd when you when you know
you hope you join the crowd
and that wesley doesn't collapse i
picked
jeffrey uh he lost in a tie break but he
did tie for first
no no that doesn't count it doesn't
count
i picked annie wang who started two out
of two
well we hope we hope you get we you
finally catch up
with the rest of the gang let's let's
hope that happens but in the meantime
let's make sure we start this off right
we want to start but
the the first move of all the games
what's our big pairing
uh duh ray robson
how is ray what is ray's approach as we
see
the v chess perspective uh
what has ray got to do
to overcome a guy who scored eight out
of nine maurice uh
as white i think how do you surprise her
you just said it i was saying i think
you're gonna play something that
wesley doesn't respond to instantly for
the first 10
15 moves got to be a little bit off the
beaten track and if you're going to play
main line and you ever had
a novelty that you've been saving for a
special
moment it is right now if
you have such a such a novelty in your
back pocket
it is right now because you can't just
play some fluff stuff
mainline that wesley's just gonna whip
out the moves instantly
you either have some major novelty that
you've been holding onto for a couple of
years
or you i just had a
flashback i just had a flashback didn't
rey and wesley play in the last round of
millionaire chess
for the for the whole thing i'm
remembering that right now
and wesley beat him so
they were they were teammates they've
had 13 games guys
on the webster team they were roommates
even
that's right and and wesley beat his
roommate it's time for some
revenge man wesley has gone in one
direction ray has stayed
pretty much where he was maybe a little
bit of improvement
he's got to make his mark right now he
can't keep losing to this guy
lots of roy lopez's um i mean and
you wonder that's a little tricky isn't
it because
wesley is just so solid with double king
pawn
is it possible rey is going to play a
different move than e4 would that just
be crazy you got to
you know play the move that you're
comfortable with he did play e4 or lexi
if he goes for the roy lopez or mixes it
up
berlin is coming guys a berlin is coming
you can bet it if bishop lands on b5
the knight will be on f6 so fast i won't
even be able to speak it
and there it is that's what i was that's
what i was thinking was going to happen
in this game but this is a
little bit concerning as it's so solid
and wesley is so
good at being solid no end game ray
comes up
no end game no there we go no way
ray likes to be as wild as possible but
how wild can it get yes
well d3 is kind of nice it provoked
bishop c6 and
on the magnus carlson tour hikaru
amongst others we're playing bishop take
c6 d take c6
and really fighting for an edge in that
position the move c2 c3
without the inclusion of bishop take c6
that's a little bit a surprise because
i think everybody knows by now that d7
d5
is a good equalizing move and
wesley played all of that a la tempo
and now we're seeing something a little
bit offbeat
this expansion on the queen side uh
bishop c4
queen d6 b4 chasing the bishop back
a for castles
hello
in your voice there as wesley is the
first one
to deviate with a novelty castles
and the reason is obviously obvious why
you're worried about it is because this
position
looks absolutely bizarre why can't you
trap the bishop
with a5 is the question is there some
kind of sacrificial play
i i would have imagined prior to the
move castles
that the that a thousand games maybe
more
have gone in this direction like this
and let the chips fall where they may
castles
[Music]
typing to me on skype so maybe he's
going to clear the cobwebs but
what is going on oh thank you interested
in a5
just briefly what can we imagine bishop
takes
f2 king takes f2 e4
is this what uh terrified let's keep
going suppose we take an e4
90 takes e4 check
can't go back to f1 or g1 that those are
forbidden
so let's say eve one two
yeah and now what no
yeah queen e7 queen g6
well uh we'll leave that uh for
as a mystery for the moment and we'll go
to what ray did play
ray played knight b d2 presumably
once again renewing the threat of a5 and
once again ignored
ignored the threat of a5 did um
oops excuse me castles uh did
uh wesley he played bishop f5
this is extraordinary can we just say
this is extraordinary
they're blitzing out these moves it must
be
all theory and we're just way way behind
in our uh opening books
maurice i would say these guys are just
playing like a lot of times it seems
like
um there's been about a dozen games
played in this
so they do know it but it's not like
it's main main line
and um but what's the situation here
both of us have a weak pawn
uh well if i just played i was about to
say it comes down to the
the fact that i just wanna you you take
the pawn on d6 i take the pawn on b4 and
i get that
very nice discovered tempo against the
bishop and i'm a happy camper
which is why rey has just played bishop
d5 getting his
uh bishop off of the exposed c four
square
but then then it does ask the question
f2 is hanging
but so is c3
so if i can get the rook either to
capture this pawn or to step back then i
will
ask what do you have for the pawn
bishop takes f2 seems like a
good question to ask you can if you go
b5 i'll drop my bishop back
what did you have for rook takes on d6
oh after oh i was just going to
i was going to be very very happy
ecstatic
about simply being able to trade off
the the you know that weak d6 pawn right
versus the pawn that's kind of
protecting white's king the c3 pawn
um yeah that's i'm thinking wesley
will be pleased with the outcome of this
opening
now bobby won against levon oronion in
2018
in this position version tells me after
bishop d5
yeah i'd like to get more details on
that game so they're still following
theory and it looks like an argument of
ideas here and that
somebody must think that there's
something here for white ray that is and
wesley must think it's it's easy
enough for him to equalize well
whenever you say fabi i'm thinking to
myself
if abby played it wesley studied it
right because there's such intense
rivalry
going on there between those two players
so
wesley is keeping a very close eye on
fabby's game so i've got a feeling
that uh wesley has worked hard on this
position because he's played it again
look at this but ray as well yeah and
ray as well
18 17
in just three minutes because he's never
seen it before now 95
seems like the first move that's truly
giving him
full pause but he decided to walk into a
main line which i feel
when i had said unless you have a
novelty
unless you have something big that you
had prepared i would
not want to be here with wesley salt it
just seems like the wrong place to be
and here we see ray is giving further
pause
i don't think he had anything prepared
it does
it is clear that wesley is very prepared
no question about it this is not looking
good
from that viewpoint that said it doesn't
mean that you're gonna
save the game or win the game or you
know even equalize necessarily
but i would have preferred to see rey in
something a bit more obscure
than a line that we know wesley has
studied
absolutely and by the way that game um
with fabi and lavonne went knight takes
e5
pawn takes e5 um king to b2
right i was about to say bishop f2
uh rook takes e5 bishop h4 rook d1
now that was at the london chess classic
in the grand chester
finals i believe that would be the third
place match
doesn't that sound right from the uh the
london finals from
two years ago yeah and wasn't it like uh
uh magnus and mvl
no it couldn't have been from two years
ago didn't fabi win two years ago
that would have been the semi-finals
where he won he
and and then not knocking
mbl magnus oh i see play because it was
a world championship and
bobby and lev lavonne had that third
place match because
bobby lost to nakamura in the in the
theater
and by the way uh the first to make a
novelty was
our own wesley sow as he's just played
not the move bishop f2 rookie five
bishop h4
as the predecessor game he just played
rook d8 at once
and i'm with you maurice it's sort of
like okay
i will try to make an argument
that uh i have some type of an edge
thanks to my queen side majority being a
little bit
more advanced than the king side
majority but i
don't think there was a tactical trick
there
oh sorry did i miss something i
apologize
one move back there's a rook c3 trick
i'm if i'm going to equalize completely
ah rook takes c3 immediately
and thanks to your bishop coming to d4
check you're saying that
maybe your king is more active and
therefore has some promise but
you feel that this should be a draw to
prove here
yeah i don't see i wouldn't i wouldn't
want to bet
the u.s championship title on a win
for white here okay what would you have
done if you were raised coach yes and i
know you don't know the ins and outs of
his opening repertoire but
would you have said the berlin end game
would you say don't even play the roy
lopez
no i i love what he did with far as
bishop b5 bishop c55
i would not have advised d3 d2 d3
i would have advised bishop takes c6
instead of the move d3 and after d takes
e6
i would have like just poured my heart
and soul into those resulting positions
because they're actually quite rich
as i discovered much to my surprise
during the magnus carlsen tour
karu you know blew away
magnus on the white side to make one of
the most
riveting matches i've ever seen in my
life
between ikaru and magnus in the finals
it was just amazing
uh so i'm just saying that i think ray
was okay but i didn't like the d3
decision now turning back to our our
attention to the moment
uh rook d8 rook d1
on the board avoiding that line that we
just saw
rook takes c e5 rook takes c3 makes a
lot of sense
but how serious is it
if let's say black plays a move like e4
with the very obvious intent of bishop
f2
followed by e3 either way
let's let's make a very important point
as e4 has
right now been played immediately not
even not trading rooks without the trade
right let's make a big point in another
game
jeffrey zhang versus alexander lindemann
jeffrey
jeffrey is hoping that rey can knock
wesley off his perch
but clear if rey doesn't
then as long as ray doesn't lose the
game
and wesley only makes a half a point if
jeffrey can win this game against
lenderman
then he can say wait a second that game
with with nakamura
for wesley in the last round that's not
going to be chicken feed
at all and if i can win 2-0
right then that ties me with wesley so
this it's good news for him at least
that ray
is not going to lose from what we could
tell that ray's not going to lose this
game
he'd rather ray win of course but at
least it's good news that
ray doesn't lose the game in which case
then you just forget it it's going to be
extremely hard hoping that wesley loses
in the last round with the white pieces
so this is a critical game we have in
front of us
does he have chances right now against
lindeman what are his chances
as the we see this queen's gambit
accepted position
which black black's pretty solid right
now but we've seen
jeffrey play some amazing technical uh
games in this tournament
he has the way he can he's very good
he's not he's not quite playing the bomb
cloud but he is going out on a limb a
little bit as he played the move 1b4
in his game i saw that yeah
probably going to play something wild
also in that game but
let's in the game against wesley take
that game real seriously because he
knows it
it affects the top boards he might play
something fun but i don't think he's
gonna play bad like you know
right yeah it's that it even if it
doesn't matter that much for him
it means the world to a couple other
players it certainly does
no and plus he doesn't want to lose
either though yeah exactly because he's
not something
that's even more unacceptable than just
playing experimental chess
but what are the chances right here yes
sir you've played this
i believe from the whites from the black
side
for sure and must have gotten it from
the white side as well the squeeze gamut
accepted
uh i see it as just being perfectly fine
for black i feel like i
to to win this position frankly speaking
i need the help of my opponent
they've got to uh they've got to get
you know give me some rope to help them
hang themselves
and this move knight e4 it's
it's actually not a move that i'm really
happy about
because you know essentially let me just
go to that game and show what i mean
uh the idea behind knight e4 is that
with the pawn on b4 you want to take
control of the
c4 square so you want to go with your
knight to d6 you want to take
take and then somehow get in e5 and
bishop e5
one day the knight lands on c4 so from
that whole perspective it's a really a
good
deal like yeah that's kind of what you
want
but from the white perspective what
white wants to do is white wants it
funnily enough he wants to take on c6 so
let me play a bad move for black and
knight take c6 and show you what i mean
this is exactly what white wants to do
white wants to
tickle the bishop as well as the b7 pawn
and get you to cooperate with me
for just a moment and you can see
suddenly like instantly in fact
uh black gets himself some trouble you
take with the rook
i take i go night here now i chase your
rook
oops and i've got this on you so
uh what i'm saying is that in a very
funny way
knight takes c6 is the threat and once
you understand the threat
you start to think to yourself well okay
great i'll avoid the threat well
i should how should i avoid the threat
95
that's one way of avoiding threat unless
i'm blundering something
horrible so i'm not
a fan of this move when
i understand what white thread is
because
it wasn't clear to me exactly well it
wasn't clear to me what
lenderman is going to be doing
with knight take c6
let's see it i see six uh
the most natural move seems like bishops
absolutely
and then we like i said we we come over
here to tickle
the bishop maybe on a good day just just
you know sending out a warning beacon uh
bishop takes a6 on my agenda
hmm this is this is actually quite
annoying
and it happens no quickly right obvious
move
bishop moves is the show okay the b71
you can't give up can you play
knight d2 or knight d6
knight now knight d2 i'm i'm afraid of
knight
my knight doesn't belong in it but
knight d6 you also have this move bishop
takes and if i take on g2
am i just yeah if i take your g2
yeah you you're just going to be in a
very
very uh awkward situation right
so that's why i'm still defended i'm
still defended
okay let's see let's see your pieces are
really discombobulated there he played
knight d6
so bishop a6 bishop g2 king g2
pawn c6 knight c6
g7 right like everything looks so
pinned up here what can we do oh yeah oh
yeah definitely
take him take
take and just start to
uh you know when i get my bishop on c5 i
play tsutsuji
against the knight and i'm looking i'm
really
just planning you know i could have put
my rook on c1 i'm just saying this is a
very
comfortable plus for white white's got a
good minor piece uh situation and he's
the one
with the more important
[Music]
rook passer you want to start yes like
if you you play rook d1 to start
are you gonna have to play like a super
passive move because you
you can't play you can play rookie eight
but then i
i can come in to c6 and maybe exactly
and then obviously the game's over right
right exactly
let's get out yeah get out of this
position let's back up so yeah
let's go to knight c6 and 96 has been
played
right and i i can't
i'm not playing rook c6 looks terrible
rookie six okay but that bishop c6
flying looked really bad too
yeah no this is rook c6 is like a
straight blunder
well i i don't want i don't want to say
blunder because
in this position a moment ago when i
played bishop e5
you did not have the move bishop d6 here
you do have the
bishop d6 but here i have maybe the
more powerful move bishop to d3
okay i it's a double attack i hit the
knight i hit the rook
if i force the trade okay well i'll you
know
seize the open file uh second trade
yeah and then if i drive you back my
knight's assertive
that's defensive that's defensive not
sure about
rook to c7 that looks good but you know
bishop e5 also feels pretty good but i
like why aren't you sure about rook c7
because of what beast i would i just
want to make sure that i'm not
blundering a back rank mate right i mean
just you know here
i don't know exactly how uh bishop b5
here i'll show you how i blunder a
backrank mate i've done it before i can
do it again
[Laughter]
yes
bishop c6 bishop c6 knight a5 on the
board
right and linderman now giving pause
is there a trick
is what is i play bishop g2
ship f6 no
sorry uh is this with the knight d6
variation this is a big thing
okay because uh again this
this ending and jen i i like your no no
no this is terrible yeah
okay but there is a trick there is a
trick there is a trick
yeah the trick is when you take on
right the bishop is saying so bishop d5
bishop david oh so my knight
you're you're going to make a you're
going to play
would you call it suzuki
against the knight on a5 right
so the whole idea being that when i drop
my bishop
back you play b6 and now it's the white
knight that's trapped well that's very
pretty
very very smart defense
that is i didn't see it it's very
sophisticated no question
i do have e4 to bail to save yourself
yeah to save myself but that's really
remarkable so
bishop takes bishop d5 i you know the
reason i think that's extremely
difficult to see
because it requires a kind of like a
quiet move
after a capture that threatened it's
it's a it's a tricky one
we'll see this he has played the opening
very quickly and he knows he's in deep
trouble
so if there's anywhere to think for
eight minutes and try to dig deep for
your defenses
now's the time but it's still like
really weird i feel like you might just
go into this variation with knight a5
and just quit
and play rook c6 and rook c7 instead
um i mean variations like allow what do
you mean he's
he's played bishop takes c6 oh yeah
he has played bishop he thinks yeah yeah
it's it's we're looking at this lord
he's played
it's on the board 95 is on the board
he's now only two moves away from this
variation we just
looked at knight 96 you you grab on a6
thinking you're doing well and then
bishop d5
and suddenly it is white who has to
start thinking about fixing the position
bishop d5 trapping that knight on a5
that's a that's really a tricky uh
move that move bishop d5 is my knight
of all pieces i was so proud of my
knight too yeah i'm gonna go
wow that's a that's a remarkable
conception indeed
nice suppose he doesn't see that like
what would he play if he doesn't see
that
well i mean why what what white could
probably oh maybe
in some world white could just probably
play a move like bishop
f1 oh well should my bishop be on f1 or
e2 i'm having troubles i just played
bishop f1
and with the idea of f3 and knight c6
d5 right okay bishop d5
now that we've learned the lesson and if
you have six
and in case of boy six okay here i just
have to pause because
he looks like he's about to move i see
him reaching for his mouse
we weren't even looking at this we
certainly were not
gonna have two it worked to d2 because
that looked like a more human
type of defense i've idea right you know
with like
getting some counter play knight d6 is
it and jeffrey was
totally ready for it and drop this
bishop on d4
instantly i mean instantly and now
the threat to the knight on f2 and the
a6 threat is back
in play and and the engine bar
went forward not not true
crazy blunder territory but it said
white's the one with the edge now
if you wanted to sharpen the game if you
were jeffrey you got it
like you just got it this is what you
wanted something in balance
you hope your opponent doesn't play
precise moves and now jeffrey
pounced with that bishop d4 and boy
that's looking very positive for him
as the other game with rey and wesley is
looking more and more drawish
by the move okay we're just gonna
uh i mean that is a fantastically
interesting game i just
pick up where we left off uh
oh you know once i see these pawns and
the bishops of opposite color ending i
just like think to myself
you know black really knows what he's
doing he's putting all of his pawns on
light squares
and i i think that wesley is
a similar color it's not opposite color
exactly bishops of similar color
but not to not not to put the pawns on
dark squares i think you're right that
wesley
is cruising to an easy draw here maybe
takes and rookie eight
would be the easiest way to simplify
going back to the jeffree game for just
a moment
so how would it go oh i was just about
uh alex beat me by
you know just a little bit i was about
to suggest
e5 so the idea is that if
you go bishop b6 i'll go rook d2 and if
you take
i'll come back with a tempo
before you land bishop a6 against me
he didn't do that alex said
i'm okay with the move knight g4 is he
okay with the move knight g4 bishop
takes a6 looks very strong
and now e5 anyway and then
if i munch god what a mess
what an ass that's a good point and now
if i well you got it to rook takes
and um everything's intake
everybody isn't b6 isn't bishop boys is
six
to happen anyway so you start where's
the counter play for
for guess we have to play rook d2 um but
there is there's nothing
except one threat yeah but what is
where's this knight going except
backwards when i hit it with h3 so kill
the bishop
and you got to take it like this
and kill the rook better kill that yeah
well just
looking at those back rank mate
possibilities
and then and then if i if i
had worse trade than yeah chase the
knight and then that a pawn
is super fast looking
very dangerous i mean that looks
i don't want this if i'm black
like bishop g5 or bishop d aiden earlier
how everything was happening so quickly
because i knew it was
all forced yet it was all tempo unless
you
maybe didn't play e5 okay
bishop g5 we have to play here
okay so we're thinking after knight g4
bishop takes a6 bishop g5
here makes sense whoa
starting out with h3 is
jeffrey so patient because he doesn't
want to help
anything like that i guess i guess he
figures he's going to get in what he
wants
anyway with bishop b6 in time
he can just chase the knight back he's
gonna play bishop a6 and go for it but
wow that is an
ultra patient move uh looking at this
looking at this engine bar it says it's
not the best move is it a voice i don't
like that
g5 in that line though that gave such
great counter play like if the knight
has to go back then jeffrey just plays
bishop a6 and it's uh it's crushing
right
for why because it's the same thing but
no counter play
well the knight has to go back we will
not even maybe
a good move that would be a great move
you just have to go back
before the knight goes back i'm really
really curious about
rook takes d4 whoa
yeah because i mean you know it's
it's it's almost like i could sacrifice
a
uh um a rook and a piece
here it's that bishop is close
because i just got it from var and var
says that the double x clan move is not
rook v4 but bishop g5
in response to h3 double x clam with the
idea that fhg4
now can
[Music]
so let's go for this line and then pawn
takes d4 bishop c1
he's nice get out of here now
and versus equal because of the threats
get out of here
please take var's computer and shove it
what are you talking about
seriously he finds that right now
that is miraculous i think the other one
with bishop d5
is even weirder because there were
active alternatives with rook d2 and
knight f2
i will say maybe leonard is going to be
forced to find something like this by
process of elimination
because after h3 if you play knight f6
you're just losing i mean
what's the deal bishop a6 and you just
die maybe he's going to look at
yaz's move instead or e5 and rook d4
um he's going to look at but he has to
look at every active move because knight
f6 or knight h6 is just like okay
bishop a6 you just you just die
necessity is the mother of invention
there jen
bishop bishop g5 right now are you crazy
what kind of move well i i mean ice
maybe i would be thinking of this right
i would be thinking this
yeah this one by the way this is
thinking what you just sacked was knight
b3
i i should have been thinking yeah
exactly i'm just saying
i would start i i would consider bishop
f6 as a legend
that loses a piece actually yeah the
reason vars is better is because
or the you know the computers of ours is
better is because
um you actually want the rook on c1 that
is a funny conception
you don't want to take your book on
anyone because then we get our work out
of the pin
that's hilarious usually the work would
be better
on the open file right exactly but in
this case get out of here
please no way if if he finds that right
now
then jeffrey just is just going to cry
if you find a bishop g5 that's
double freaking triple x it is what was
once
what was e5 e5 e5 is the move i'm sure
he's also furiously calculating we just
said that bishop b6
rook d2 and now um
oh i i think i i thought you were going
to take on c6 and
yeah why don't no he was taking c6 rook
c6 yeah i guess
so i mean this is this this is like a
very natural line to look at yeah
that rook takes c6 i i i help
black if i take so so you have to go for
that line
no no i i but here you can play rook
sorry yes
there you can play bishop f1
okay sorry excuse me so knight takes six
and wesley and ray have drawn so that's
we're not we expected that so i must win
games
bishop f1 here what's the deal i got oh
no you should
take on b6 because there's no backpack
yeah bishop f8
yeah bishop bishop is coming okay so
then
the white house is the thing that jazz
was talking about allowing work g2
so let's check that again
yes i thought we you have a
you mentioned that a draw has been
agreed right so i grabbed a lot of pawns
but i don't believe it i i think that uh
i think that white should be the one for
choice
um unfortunately though for lenderman i
think because this line exists
he's he might not find bishop g5 if if
he was going to resign with any other
variation maybe by process elimination
he would find this spectacular idea but
because this one is exists and it
doesn't look
like it's resignable i feel like he
might just play this one
it's almost like unfortunate for him
that he has that well look look look at
him right look what he's doing look at
his
this hand this this calculating hand
look at him
look this is an aha moment like a light
bulb yuri
he might have seen it he might just
might have seen this variation
well he had some clarity there in a
moment does he find bishop g5 as his
hand
has gone down now it's like he's reached
for
the mouse the problem as i see it jen
is he's going to find bishop g5 because
even though you might try to convince
yourself that this is
not that bad and in fact it really is it
really is
uh very good for white right i mean this
bishop this knight
he found it he found it unbelievable
wow wow yes bishop d5 necessity is the
mother of invention everything else
loses as
jen was saying uh bishop g5 okay
tip your hat big applause jeffrey is
oh what a move
what a bomb and by the way
for jeffrey he doesn't have many options
here that's the next question
what do you do here exactly you don't
have to do you have to accept this
variation
takes rook takes takes is there another
move
okay let's see well first of all let's
reject the obvious you
it's not like you can move the bishop
away because bishop takes e3
check is the answer to any
uh bishop moves and then you're just two
pawns down
and you're unhappy so no bishop moves
bishop e6 that looks kind of ridiculous
maybe it's not as ridiculous as it looks
i don't think we have to treat
everything and close down the shop
because what if we play the main line
just h takes g4 rook d4 bishop c1 rook
c1 bishop d5 and we get like a knight to
c5 wait what's the pawn count
it's they say we just move our words
we play rook b1
okay who's better here are we down are
we down upon
no we're not now not if you take them
we're threatening knight v6
bishop d5 knight c5 i mean considering
jeffrey needs a win
maybe he'll that's that's playable this
could be
is this better for white or black i
don't know who's better
very concerned about white's pawns on
the king side
than
[Music]
bishop d no yes bishop d3 i could have
played maybe rookie e1 because rook d1 i
play bishop e2
or rook c3 is another move but bish rook
d1 you're telling me you're not gonna
accept uh
material you're gonna go down material
so if i could play bishop d3 in this
moment gain a tempo
then i'm gonna sneak my rook in on the
other side
and this yeah i think i think this is
one to start the variation like bishop
b5 rook d1
but but guys my point is if if jeffrey
can get anything with play
even if it's chances for him to lose
that's better at this point because
if he only draws this game he's really
looking
down the barrel in terms of his chances
for um you know winning
i mean what does he do like single
digits it might be
winning and wesley has to lose and
he has to um also win the playoff like
that
that would be the parlay if he only
draws this game
right i just does he play i don't see
how to get anything
and what do we came up with with bishop
oh so you're trying rook c2 okay and
then bishop d
bishop i'm just yeah i was just like
looking at that bishop ending and saying
no no no
it's not not enough but to your point
jen
after let's say rook e won
maybe your rook is i don't know better i
think you're just running into the same
kind of stuff well if bishop five now
knight c5 so at least i can
then you can close it that then you get
what you wanted which was the good
blockading night
and that made it this is better work on
like a better
try but you know i think it's
it's it's it's not a
it's not a very good uh winning chance
in my view
i mean you can put your knight on c5 you
can be happy about that
but this bishop is actually pretty darn
good
i mean it will eventually get to a very
nice square the king
will but yes sir your last name though
was dangerous
king fa rook c1 is a is a problem
king f8 rook c1 i overdid it did i
yeah now your rook gets the open file
probably that's
true
and id6 followed by rook c7 is
unnecessary
for black to fall into but it's worth
playing
i mean this would be worth playing i'll
take this it's worth
it's worth playing you know because uh
he needs his win
and it is going to be a blitz game i
mean they've got seven minutes now but
you know in a few minutes they're gonna
have three-minute seats like
you know hey like try to play we've seen
stranger things happen in this
championship
okay but bishop g5 is such a spectacular
move that one you're buried
in analysis for quite some time if you
didn't see it coming
it's the kind of punch you want to land
on somebody with the black pieces
the more linderman looks at this the
more confident he becomes that it's
correct
jeffrey now has been sitting for about
five minutes trying to work this out as
we've been
and he's trying to find what's the line
that keeps the fire and is it really
true
i mean he has to settle down first say
it's actually true
this clown gets out of this with some
sick bishop g5 sack on f2 drop your
knight back
hang your knight cycle on d4 come on
really i mean how unlucky can jeffrey be
that these pyrotechnics are coming at
him
yeah just remarkable and in it and again
the move bishop g5 spectacular
but forced i mean every other move loses
so
you know jeffrey's sitting there saying
okay you've got all of these
great other moves that you can consider
how do you come up with bishop g5 well
because i calculated everything else was
terrible bad
bad luck for jeffrey there that
that and and alex i mean you got to tip
your hat
bishop g5 is a great find but guys he
sacked the
the same knight twice on you yeah he did
i mean the same knight got stopped
in g4
here you see the ball here you don't i
mean this is amazing tactics we've seen
the variation actually play itself out
instantly and now jeffrey's got to
decide
where is the plus here to play for is
there any life
in this position if he only draws if he
only draws the game wesley
remains a full point ahead of him going
into the last round with a big game
against nakamura but he will have the
white pieces with wesley
that's going to be very hard to catch
and by the way wesley um did finish his
game early so i bet you he was watching
this and like
when he saw the move bishop g5 he was
like
yeah baby
alex all-star move guys that is
incredible dinner's on me nice
nice i'm i'm trying to i mean it's
remarkable that i don't have some
variation where i can play bishop takes
deep
like i i i was like you know
we got an x-clam um var by the way he
says after bishop d5
the best move is rook a1 what
wow what what what what i guess to
i guess to anticipate the rook landing
on
c3 that you want your pawn
defended what i mean
but we were going to put our work on our
knight on c5 to plug you up anyway no
and he went for this bishop end game and
yeah what's in it i don't think what
what is anything
here i mean i'm even worried that it's
it's worse for him
of course it's worse look at this uh
look at this beautiful
uh bevy of majority over here versus
these two uglies okay is d5 no you get
to d4 but that's all you get
maybe he thought that the end game with
knight vs bishop was also
better for black so he just went in for
this he might have thought he was in
trouble
that's what it indicates that he's going
for this end game i think
this position why isn't white in trouble
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
when somebody plays a move like bishop
g5 on you
we could sit here and talk about it
discuss
somebody drops bishop g5 with all those
moves knight f2 knight g4 rook b4
your brain goes another way you don't
just sit calm
down let me see if i can get this
slightly better because you're like what
what just happened what just happened
and look at how he played
he played like a man who got a
big punch in the face and he's just
trying to get up off the mat get to the
corner somewhere
and say did you see that train that just
ran over me
because those last moves were
unbelievable they were just completely
next level kudos to lindeman for
hitting jeffrey like this and jeffrey
just goes into a position that's not
an optically yes or you're loving black
yeah i'm
i'm thinking black's winning i
i in my view black is ready to go king
e7 king d6
so that deals with this guy and it
really means that i'm close to the king
side
put my king on d6 then i'm going to put
my bishop on c8
and then i'm going to play f5 and g5
and if i force you to take then i've got
three versus one you've got a g
pawn i've got f5 g5 and h6 i've got a
king you've got a passer
but you've got these two uglies that are
doubled
and your king is stuck on e3 and your
bishop is going to be stuck
so i'm oh he didn't go for
the line i just prescribed but he can
get there uh
that is to say uh and we see jeffrey now
just basically moving his bishop back
and forth hoping for a whole different
mindset
you see that jeffrey's mindset is i
gotta get out of here alive
yeah he played for an ending that he
hopefully could draw because
he recognizes bishop g5 was so tough but
we we could see without any issue in our
minds because we're not playing
right now that he had a chance moves
like rook a1
brook worked to e1 that he had a chance
but we didn't see rook a1
it's ridiculous but we don't understand
why that one was better than rook ivany
yeah we saw rook we saw rook e1 as a
logical
but in his mind that that guys that was
total history
the way the guy just played on you when
you sack three four different stylish
times on somebody
their brain goes a different way and
he's just decided let me shut this down
i need a drawer we just saw a move by
lenderman which basically says
okay i'm not quite sure what i'm doing i
i thought lenderman was playing g5 c8
f5 it's a draw as wesley so retains his
full point lead
yep he's playing white against nakamura
in the last round
with a draw he will clinch victory and
this is the moment
that lenderman said eureka i found it i
am not in trouble anymore i have this
brilliant idea bishop d5
apparently like um beth harmon and the
queen's gambit
looking up at the ceiling sometimes
gives you
unique inspiration although
i i don't think is is realistic but
no spoilers you guys can see the see the
series for yourself and decide please
please don't talk about it i'm i'm on
page 183
in the book only about one 60 pages to
go
that's episode one that's episode
don't talk about it by the way it's
really wonderful that not only is
queen's gambit playing right now on
netflix and
it's the number one netflix series in
america which is amazing
uh chess the musical chess the musical
premiered
in moscow yeah october 17th
uh that and and apparently to rousing
rousing applause a 20-minute standing
ovation at the end
how's that 20-minute standing ovation
how do you get a 20-minute standing
ovation
that's insane yes indeed but it's
playing
we've got the u.s championship we've got
nakamura at 550
000 followers on twitch i mean chess is
really
seeing an incredible resurgence
not since not seen since the bobby
fisher days guys this is
really amazing it is and by the way
there's another chess movie out called
critical thinking that i really as well
wow just uh a completely great time
for chess of course difficult time for
many all over the world but
happy to see the chess um both fictional
and real is providing some solace and
entertainment
hey it's inexpensive entertainment guys
and that's why it connects everybody all
over the world
just switching to the hikaru game for
just a moment i just saw this
last move h4 and you know rook endings
notoriously drawn and
three versus three and you know white's
got to pass pawn and black's got to pass
pawn
but it feels to me like i'd rather be
black
this king is basically in
easy touching zone of uh dealing
with the d-pawn whereas it's not that
easy for
for white to get his pieces over
to deal with the h-pawn so
i mean even though yeah i'm sure
the the engines are going zero zero zero
and whatnot
uh sitting at the board in hikaru shoes
i would feel nervous i would think that
uh
what about darius issues with 24 seconds
left
that's the problem it's it's the time
the time factor the time control is the
issue
but from dari's point of view i mean
it's pretty easy what he's going to do
he's going to move his rook he's going
to move his pawn and he's going to try
to promote it
you don't need that much time to play
those moves
by the way we did see a draw in el
shawn's game against alejandro so those
players
are moving right along we see why did
sam and
a wonder dude i'm gonna wander look like
they're gonna draw easily as well
so we haven't seen a single victory is
this going to be the first round we see
zero volumes why is this such an easy
draw for a wonder
like i'm just looking sorry i just uh
picking up on the game between sam
savion
and i wonder if white takes if you take
with the b-pawn well this
pawn is fast so i'm assuming you're
taking like this and i'm going
d six and i'm hoping for
[Music]
there's a knight e4 check well
it's trickier than it looks but i
think white's for choice maybe he maybe
sam should just
actually just start with the move g4
takes f5
as these two great junior players
battle it out how old is sam by the way
he's on 19. he turns 20 into something
yeah okay
okay so jeffrey celebrates his birthday
tomorrow savion later in the year
king to g3 play king to g3 just
keeping all the tension
and i'm i'm wondering what his intention
is after king f6
it's not like the king is going to go uh
marching forcefully up the board okay um
let's go back to the game of ikaro for a
moment because
it's really this is a heated position
just a second so hold on we he went
rook here h3 d6
this could be one of those positions
where we see queens in the near future
rook is coming to
how does this go guys i'm just i'm
having uh
i'm having trouble understanding what
hikaru's plan
how does hikaru plan on meeting rook h1
so d7 gets checked
and i grab the pawn king e2
runs into this variation and i get to
promote with check
[Music]
um if that's not the end of the
variation it might
not be the blunder d6 is a blunder
because daryl is not winning
but not with the way he played
apparently because
the engine is not happy with what he did
at all
was there a better move
because right here it was a blunder by
darrow apparently
what was a blunder by daryl um the move
rook to d1
check was the blunder and instead h2
immediately was winning
and by the way i think i saw darrow
shake his head i think he saw
immediately after he played it after the
move
we're showing yes h2 and then if um
if uh you play d7 at that point
um you you play rook d1 shaq and queen
right
correct yeah yeah you start with king e2
or
whatever you just move your rook over
right
and but i thought kc3 i thought king c3
was the only one
right but that's the problem
yes right yeah to get
and then and then you're winning and
then oh
um okay so you just snap up a pawn and
then just move your king into f4
okay it'll be a while but yeah sorry let
me just
refresh he noticed because i saw him
like put his face in his hand
soon after playing on rook v1
exactly exactly
that would be a huge scalp for him you
know uh
the not having a great tournament but
hey
anytime you you beat this rapid and
blitz legend it's
a scalp to remember seriously
and it there is something incredibly
peculiar i
i haven't figured it out in a physical
physics particle kind of way it's like
the moment you lift up your hand
after you've completed your move it's
exactly the time that you realize you
made a blunder
i mean it's like you see it only
afterwards
remarkable what's happening here two
past pawns connected
black is completely winning isn't he um
no it's a draw because you it takes you
so much time
to get your king in
into play um you'll lose a pawn
you never get your king you're never
getting your king into the plane has to
sit where it is
you need the king to win the rook in two
versus rook
precisely you absolutely need your king
you cannot just use
the pawn rook and pawns by themselves so
this one is clearly a draw
and that and he's just he's just
acquiesced and played rookie for
and the players will agree to it yeah
why isn't hikaru taking the pawn
okay it makes zero sense right
finally let me just check in uh lanier
and uh sam and made the draw
sometime ago yeah yeah
many wonder is the last game remaining
we have no wins
so far this round and it doesn't look
likely that this one is going to be a
win either
yes no yeah there's four verse four with
knights
yes yes i'm going to tell you that game
that game that linderman decided to play
like
an absolute super genius as this one is
repeating as well
to find knight f2 knight g4 bishop g5
rook bishop d5 b6
oh my goodness i mean if he played like
that the whole tournament
he he'd have a score but in an
individual game he was able to find
just simply amazing moves
and jeffrey is thinking why you pick me
like
why could you play somebody else like
this you picked me in the round 10
when i really needed it this is
no victims guys no easy victims so
and we'll see the end of the wesley soul
game on v-chess a game where
ray robson's opening preparation did not
leave him much of an edge hey i mean we
know wesley is incredibly solid when he
needs to draw one to draw
it's it's a tall order his opening
repertory
just so solid if he needs it to be so
um ray still having a fantastic event as
is jeffrey's but now their odds of
winning this championship
are very low they will require them to
win their final round game
um wesley has to lose and they have to
beat him in a playoff
so a three-part plan hey they're gonna
try
but not very likely and they're gonna
have to win with black too
jen well that is less um unlikely based
on this tournament i mean both of them
had
incredible victories with black so many
beautiful
wins but you know uh i think
wesley losing with white is is the hard
part
and guess what they don't control that
does anyone remember ray robson losing a
game this tournament
oh he lost jeffrey yeah he lost to
jeffrey
yesterday so jeffrey beat him wesley
beat
jeffrey and that's the that's the ball
game that's yeah
the difference in the tournament right
there that's the tri party if you will
and
there we have it there we have our
standings as we have
in all draw penultimate round wesley so
fades white against nakamura in the
final round and if he gets a draw
he is a 2020 us chess champion
jeffrey zhang ray robson i mean hats off
to both of these young men for their
tremendous results
they still have a mathematical chance
guys we we have to keep our eyes on that
sonakamora game as
they are both going to try to win with
black to continue
their incredible results and check out
this
championship gear i've seen a lot of the
players wearing those beautiful hoodies
guys
during the games it is fall and we're
creeping into winter you
can get some of this gear as well at two
boutiques
louis dot com and you can also get it as
gifts
as the holidays are coming around and
that mask looks really pretty
i like the two-tone gray right
very comfortable
and after everything's done tonight and
that's going to be 5 p.m
central time we are going to have our
combined 2020 u.s chess championships
losing ceremonies
all five events so we're gonna see all
five winners be recognized
and you can watch on st louis tesco's
youtube or twitch channels
and also uschestchamps.com
and congratulate the winners
and we're gonna take a quick break while
we bring you
in just a few minutes the final round of
the 2020
us chess championship
[Music]
okay so let's say i go to f1 right just
as a to pick a square
and g3 yeah
okay well uh d5 d6
yeah you know see
oh you want to check me you already have
my rook there's a way to win the rook
yeah check and check and take the rook
check because you can't play king g2
because the knight f4
check you have to play games at the end
of the day am i
oh at the end of the day you're queening
well i got d7 though
you won my rook but you won that battle
but not poor
so you're saying after i'm not quite
coming back in time
um i don't have a way to get back you
could try
instead perhaps this one yeah okay that
looks better right and then after
g6 and then this one
this one yeah but uh
what about king e5 exactly king e5
now it's a different matter you didn't
want to
calculate this no nobody wants to
calculate that
that wasn't good so uh
92 check king f1 so maybe a different
move here instead of rushing with g3
but that d6 pawn is
is interested in marching down the board
that's a surprise that really is
putting your king in the corner whoa and
so now
are the same lines on tap yes
well if g3 it's a similar variation
right after
d6 we're you know sorry so
there is rook check check right away you
can't
go king here to g2 because i've got that
knight f4 you got to go king h2
got g3 check and then
king h3 knight of four yeah exactly
you got it you got it you got it back
here you got a sack
well i think you know maybe jeffrey was
worried about
if king f1 king e3 trying to
still maintain the checkmate hunt rather
than just rush with g3
right but in any case 18 seconds left as
nakamura is looking to the side nodding
his head
right he can be and there we have rook
f6 played
yeah what's going on so there was 92
king h1
and then what happened king h1 and then
uh six played
no king e3 king e3 g3 rook f6
yeah three requests uh-huh keeping the
king away
but it feels like your king is going to
die it does
it does feel like the king is going to
die the part ends up on g2 this is over
yes all the way to g2
this is straightforward over now right
rook a1 check
king 2 it doesn't matter everything's
going to happen with check
and then g3 jack king h1 h3
forced check let's see the moves on your
board
yes as he has only 20 seconds left
that's all
well we can show it afterwards as the
clock is ticking down so precipitously
he sees that it's just going to be
forced every move a check that pawn is
going to end up on g2
with all forcing moves six seconds left
four
and he's finally moved but richie one
check
and we still get to the pawn to g3 with
jack that's right
he can't play it instantly exactly
followed by rook so g3 checks
h1 check your king is forced to go up to
g4 the pawn goes to g2
we will have our first winner rook h1
momentarily king cannot go backwards
because of rook g2 check and then
i mean and then g2 check uh forces mate
and that's what a game by now
as jeffrey looks like he might resign
right now and there it is nakamura is at
least
tied for the lead in the us chess
championship very likely to have just
won his fifth title
but to confirm that we have to check in
on dominguez and guerrero as if that
game is draw
this is your u.s champion hikaru
nakamura
and one more move
and that's all the draw can simply be
accepted now he's putting a knife back
on g7 realizing his bid
to win his first u.s title is finished
finally
spectacular results will be sure but not
enough
as they are moore is now the champion a
draw
seals the deal congratulations to hikaru
nagamora we see him waiting
for his moment he now wears the crown
five-time us champion
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession
isn't a notepad camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it verifying it and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts
into context examining all the arguments
and including
differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted
we work every day to earn your trust
for news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
the st louis chess club world chess hall
of fame
and legendary world chess champion gary
kasparov
invite you to attend strategy across the
board the virtual fourth annual gala
a fundraiser to advance st louis through
the artistic
cultural and educational value of chess
strategy across the board will be held
online tuesday december 1st
from 6 30 to 8 pm central standard time
come celebrate with us reserve your
virtual ticket now
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton
of fun stuff for families to do like the
magic house
or the science center and if you really
want to be a
stellar parent come see all the new
stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze
light shows and the 20-story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent
feel like a star st lou
is always exploring
when i was growing up in chess there was
a chess legend
he was a giant in the american chess
scene his name was
sammy or samuel ruschevsky he did
everything to
try to disturb his opponents and there
are just
so many very bad stories about sami and
in this particular case
both sammy and his opponent were in time
trouble
a lot of people wrongfully think that
all of the
chess rules are chiseled in stone and
that has been the case for the last 500
years
not so and for example at one time
the rule of chess was that if you and
your opponent
got into time trouble and one of you
lost
the game on time you
were required to inform the arbiter stop
the clock
and say i win today the arbiter
can stop the clock as well but
in those days there was no outside
influence and it was
up to the players to to inform
the arbiter that their opponent had lost
so the players are getting into a big
time scramble
200 people breathlessly watching the
game
and suddenly in the front row
uh the wife of samuel rasheff he jumps
out of her seat
and shouts in the loudest voice possible
flag
for an egg flag and a
ruszewski quickly stops the clock says
you're down
i win well
the shock to the opponent of this
extraordinarily
loud screeching voice
and everything else he complains
and immediately there convenes a appeals
committee
to deal with the protest that sammy got
outside interference so the appeals
committee decides that
indeed that was the case and that the
game is to continue from
the position sammy says no no no no
there was no
outside interference and the arbiter
said but
i'm sorry sammy there was 200
spectators that clearly heard your
wife screaming flag no no no
sesame according to talmudic law
my wife and i are of one flesh
and therefore there was no outside
interference
one flesh and sammy was upheld
and he won the game by forfeit
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 u.s
chess championship as we just have one
round to go
until we crown our champion and very
likely it will be
leslie solis he is currently a full
point ahead
of two incredible
contenders jeffrey zhang and ray robson
formidable scorers guys usually they
would have a chance
to win in this final round to get eight
and a half points that would match
irena crushes for in the u.s women's
championship
but this event leslie is just on fire
and if he gets to that magic nine
against nakamura
he will seal his crown i was about to
say
uh scoring 75 after 10 rounds i would be
saying
if i was in rey or jeffrey's shoes you
know where's my first place check that's
huge
it's this man wesley so who's just been
playing
i i hesitate to guess but i'm gonna
say a tpr tournament performance rating
of 2900
i mean that's just a monster monster
score that he's racked up
never saw that coming i thought hikaro
was a favorite
remarkably enough hikaru
could play the spoilers role uh
how badly do you think hikaru would like
to do that
personally i don't think he's caring
about this at all last game he could
have lost as well
the car was feeling right he's playing
terrible chess
to pick himself up right now and somehow
play wesley who's been resting
all this time lounging since drawing a
long time ago
against ray robson i just find it very
hard to believe that hikaru has
any desire in this event right now if
the wesley were maybe a half a point
ahead
but a full point i don't know
guys i mean he's streaming on his twitch
channel
for like you know thousands of viewers
and i think that maybe he wants to just
have a game because it's a dramatic
story arc that is a possibility
no i'm not sure i wouldn't be shocked if
he if he
you know draws the game in you know
whatever a
lesser known amount of views moves than
we're used to but
i also want to be shocked if he just
goes for some kind of like really
interesting variation like the perk
just to say this is something for my
fans to watch
all over the world and you know maybe
give uh the other contenders in the
tournament a chance
it's gonna be about the first move if he
plays e4 e5
it's a draw if he plays e4 g6 or e4 d6
you might have a little game guys
yeah a little
performance rating so he can only get to
3 000 if he beats not more right now
by the way let's make a point wow
let's make another stat that i was told
by ed gonzalez and thank you ed for
everything you have
sent our way in these u.s championships
all these beautiful nuggets and
the letters that you send ed because of
course he is um works for
the us postal service so he helps out in
many more ways than one right now so
let me let me tell you this that that i
asked ed this morning i was curious
about and he came back
with the answer rapidly he said
i said so what's the what's the best
score
to win a championship like if wesley
gets nine
who's got nine points out of
11 11 now how far do you think we have
to go back
to get nine points way back
right i mean be beyond i'm saying excuse
me out of the numbers eleven zero out of
11.
yes exactly yeah zero is the best
forever
right right right who's the number two
scorer ever best ever
out of eleven out of out of eleven out
of eleven yes fisher was 11-0
we're talking about a 12-player
invitational fischer was 11-0
who's number two it's easy guess
fischer again fisher again nine and a
half
out of 12 out of 11. right it's fisher's
second best score who's number three
you're gonna say bobby right bobby again
stands alone with nine
out of 11. we're good at this game
what is it one answer in three questions
and then no one else has ever done it
no one bobby fisher that
when we get to eight and a half there's
a group suddenly there's a group
nakamura has done it did in 2012.
sam shanklin has done it uh he did it
just now and he went plus six
or up last year and won well so has just
done it
as well was he so big those got eight
and a half
if wesley draws this game he's the he
has the third best record in a 12-player
invitational
in u.s championship history drawing
bobby fischer tying i mean
bobby fischer for that result that's
what we're looking at right now
he's going to like epic performances
ever to have your name it's like having
your name next to michael jordan folks
your name alongside bobby fisher's
for our performance that's if he gets
only a half point
if he gets the full point he ties
fischer's rec
score in 1966 at nine and a half of
course fisher's 11-0
may never be repeated again for another
100 plus years
if ever but if he if he does that right
now he can either
he draws now he ties bobby for third if
he
wins he ties bobby for a second by the
way we should point out that
at eight and a half karana also did that
in 2016
a remarkable score and the other two
people were
larry evans and who at eight and a half
come on guys it's easy by the way here
it is wait leslie
it's bobby fisher it's bobby fisher yeah
bobby fischer also had an eight and a
half score
so fischer has all the numbers and then
here we go
we get d4 in that fighter six with a
nimzo on the board
and this is good news guys this looks
more likely to be a real game
[Music]
no um this might be over in two minutes
yeah exactly what is it the fourth draw
line
this is the first drawing yeah oh no
yes with this crazy g5 business
it's it's a crazy g5 business that
has been played on the very highest
level for some time now
and it just every time i see it it's
like i get a
brain infarction i mean it's just an
amazing uh
sequence of super super sharp moves
and look at the car we're just leaning
back and
they're whipping out all these moves and
they're playing what looks like such a
sharp variation it is a sharp line of
course
but it's all known it's all three it's
all theory
and hikaru has far more time than he
started with
so does wesley this move e6 has given
him pause for the first time
not much of a pause as capture capture
as we see things just being
hoovered off the chessboard guys
cleaning this isn't what we were afraid
of
we will be giving wesley so a coronation
very short exactly exactly so
um was that it was that an intentional
pun and let's
let's see why knight f5 has been played
okay
so the winning threat of queen e5 by the
way
yes so we got to play we gotta either
take the knight or play rookie eight
right exactly i mean there's no choice
and he chose rookie eight now
uh i just a second
i know this is what
what do i know i mean i have to remember
97
check 99 check king
king over and then queen d4 jack and i
get the bishop but then you get queen c5
check
i know there's a i know there's a line
that that's supposed to go like this
so king g7 let's say queen d4 check f6
queen takes check queen check
uh queen um but instead uh
wesley started with queen d5 threatening
knight e7 winning the queen so bishop f5
rook f5 queen e2
are all fours and here we have
a very two very exposed kings with
perpetuals on the offense or wholesale
trades
right exactly i wouldn't expect
f1 queen e3 check
king g2 queenie to check
rook f2 and indeed we see
work f1 queen e3 tech is on the board
and isis oops excuse me i
suspect rook e
rook f1 f2 queen e1
czech rook f1 why nothing
there um i would
well are we trying i i'm trying to force
a draw
queenie for check we still play right
right
i want to force
why can't you play king g2 after this
well are you playing for a winner you're
playing for a draw i'm saying if you
play for a draw i would play rook f2
because rook f2 forces you to play
queenie one check
i play rook f1 you're forced to play
queen e3
this is awesome we're seeing it all guys
it's all just flying
and the draw is done wesley so is the
champ we knew
that there was anything for hikaru to
play for
it's a full points are the black pieces
these super gm's don't mess around in
that situation
they sure don't anticlimactic but the
real money game
was ray robson's game and unfortunately
he picked
the wrong opening and wesley sowe is
indeed the champ with a result that
matches
bobby fischer one of the most
spectacular results we've ever seen
in the history of these championships
congratulations
job to wesley so as he played some
really
memorable games not today but in the
last few days
he played especially days two and three
day one you know he won all three games
but they were
more up and down he was even in trouble
in some of them but
days two and three man he had some
sparklers
you know the money game i said that last
round was the money game
the real money game that separated him
was the one he beat
jeffrey exactly that game was just nip
and tuck and jeffrey could have drawn at
the very end with that
bishop fortress against the rook if
jeffrey had found that we would have
come into the into today with
a whole different type of game but
because jeffrey
had beaten ray and wesley said okay well
then i got to beat you
and he beat jeffrey that changed the
whole complexion
and made it very difficult that's right
and that was a brilliantly played game
by wesley
forty thousand dollars in the title of
2020 a us chess champion
i mean you know it it's like when he won
that game against jeffrey you could
really see
how incredible wesley is as not only a
great chess player but also just such a
great practical chess player
because it was hard to fault jeffrey at
all in the game he played great chess
and wesley is is very well mannered and
you know he always has something nice to
say but you could decode with his words
the one thing jeffrey didn't have that
wesley had was impeccable time
management
yes and i gave him that win and it gave
him the tournament
that was it that was the difference
because wesley if jeffrey at the time
he would have found the defense that i i
just said and
then he would have drawn the game and
we'd have had a whole different story
by the way i've just been told a stat
that i can't
even understand uh nakamura has played
how many
u.s championships
high double teams 15. two and he's clean
no i think last i'm gonna go with the
under 12.
i'm not sure the number i know it's in
the teens okay so
but nakamura i mean think about this for
a second what i'm about to say
nakamura's result according to ed
gonzalez
is the first ever minus score he's ever
scored in the u.s championship wow
ever wow because because when he first
started playing the us championship
he was a baby wow
but it was a 64 player field and you
know as a kid your car was already
really good that kind of kid exactly
it wasn't like he was you know 2500
rolling up into like
this 12 player invitational um he was
getting plus scores right at the gate
but think about it he's the best it was
a swiss and i play him in round one i
think one of the first times he played
what would you have guessed that the
number one
all-star online rapid player we have
right now
in the world okay magnus carlson may
argue
sorry that's that's not quite the case
relax but
hikaru is up there as top two nobody's
arguing that right
right would you imagine that he would
finish on a
minus score in this field
a minus it goes to show how strong this
field is and
maybe what poor form hikaru is in
but no i would never have guessed that
maurice no not at all and the score i'm
sorry as strong as you can make this
field yes
it's not like the magnus carlsen tour i
mean yeah and it's
in fabi fabi as we know there was that
scheduling conflict with the candidates
they can
fabi declined his invitation and then
they
moved the candidates oops right so no
fobby as well
as well he was coming in thinking it was
going to be him he and wesley
to dominate and he got a minor score in
the u.s championship in a
rapid online event remarkable
what's a wonder score will a wander pass
him well
i mean there are a number of players who
may have a better result than him
at the end of the day because certainly
ray and jeffrey and a bunch of players
are ahead of
the good news by the way just a bad
tournament but he's just so
successful lately that i compared to the
other players
um you know not to delve into anybody's
financial situation but we know nakamura
signed with tsm a major esports company
he's crushing it on twitch and youtube
so i don't think he really cares about
those price jumps as
much as you know most chess players do
and maybe that's part of the problem
when he's not in the running for first
he doesn't have that inherent
motivation that everybody does although
i don't know about that because he likes
to win
a bullet game for no money so that yeah
i'm i'm surprised you're talking about
money right now
it's like it's hikaru nakamura it's
competitive repetitive people you've
ever met in your life
but it's not at least he doesn't have to
um you know he's not
he's upset because he didn't do well in
this tournament he's not as concerned
with the
intrinsic other factors in the event um
but yeah i mean it's been a great year
for him and this is one of the few
setbacks he's had and
that happens you know every every chess
player encounters setbacks why
um it's okay it's really going to be
hard to psychoanalyze that one guys
quick quick quick timeout for a second
just want to return to the game for a
moment
because one of the things that you said
maurice kind of surprised me
forty thousand first twenty five
thousand
second what was it for third sixteen
thousand
so you said there was a nine thousand
dollar differential right
between second and third okay i think
when i won
four u.s championships first with six
thousand okay
and jeffrey and
uh ray robson essentially have a nine
thousand dollar swing because second
yeah they're
they're secured so we can get to the
games maybe
they have some intrinsic uh
interest in the outcomes of these two
games alejandro ramirez
jeffries young alejandro has just played
the move a5
i'm expecting castles by
jeffrey from from my point of view
jeffrey should be very very happy
because he's got one of those positions
where it's really imbalanced uh
a board full of pieces and that's just
exactly the kind of position he needs
if he's going to win with black so we're
going to keep an eye on this game in the
game
by the way speaking of uh streaming
grandmaster ray robson also streams
jeffrey john
doesn't as far as i know um and i think
rachel's
not on the level of nakamura he's not
doing it day in and day out
but he does so those of you who've
become fans of him here certainly check
him out
ray robson um god he inspired me in this
event guys
like his games were just so fun to watch
you know we we had some we had a ray
robinson in every single event i think
like where you just looked at their
games and like things were just blowing
up right like a swarm
or talia right there they were people in
the women
and the girls who who were like that and
and burke in the us junior
right he ended up winning but throughout
the event we noted that
yes and the ending
yes yes good call yeah the telltale sign
uh that we've seen historically is
losing
a game in the u.s championship means
you're not going to win the two blemish
yeah we've seen that i mean what was the
last one something like 2000 or
even earlier the last player to win an
invitational by
after losing a game like you can't lose
you're just like you can't lose that's
the big thing and wesley
did not lose a single game jeffrey and
ray
lost one game that's that was the
differential
but like you said yes there's a lot
of money at stake for these young men
nine thousand dollar potential swing or
if they
tie then they'll split this this purse
is 41 000
and uh that's not gonna be bad money
twenty thousand five hundred if
they can do that but that's still
substantially less than they could get
if they win and the other guy doesn't
win so they are
going for it so that's right 20k if they
tie for first and by the way i think
this
the silver medal in this event is quite
prestigious yes it's not the title
but you say you're runner-up in the u.s
championship and you know what kind of
players playing the u.s championship
it's something it is definitely
something that you can keep that you can
put on your resume a resume builder as
you know for either ray or jeffrey um
although we expect many more um
championship runs from these guys based
on the way they're playing here
no question about it dude the game of
ray robson versus lenderman
again i think this is a position that
rey will
embrace uh he's black he's got the two
bishops he's given
up uh a pawn
but got a double uh e pawns as a
compensation and i'm thinking that
okay i will put white's last move was by
the way
knight on d2 to f3 eyeballing knight to
d4 so i would put my bishop
back on the c5 square looking at e3
uh preparing bishop to e6
and i'm thinking it's a three result
game
and so as rey i would be
pleased with the outcome of the opening
and he's played the move bishop c5
and we're going to keep an eye on this
game as well as the jeffrey
young game we've just seen an exchange
on b6
alejandro is happy that he's opened up
the a
file um how do you guys uh
rate this position between alejandro
and jeffrey hmm
my god instinct says that
white doesn't have much
but that b-pawn on b6 become a little
nugget
i need i need to see a few more moves i
need to see the white knight on d2
find a homo when that knight finds
somewhere else to be that
it's really nice is it knight f1 e3 d5
i don't know is that substantial
i like black i mean i like white sorry i
like white but i feel
like um jeffrey
has been outplaying his opponents in a
lot of positions where there's more
juice so he's probably not that
disappointed either
well this one's gonna grow the distance
i think it's not gonna be gonna be like
some kind of quick
quick uh liquidation or anything oh
absolutely not
break down the advantages that you like
about the
white position i know you like to play
sicilians and stuff
no i do like the place of silence but
like there's already this open
a file and there's this like nicely
placed
knight on d4 and you know if i ever
would be able to get my knight on c4
right now it's covered but maybe i can
protect that square i just think that
you know you can't really land a knight
on c5 or e5
because i have these ready-made b4 f4
brakes
so i'm just a little confused i guess
with my concern i'm not
really sure what black's plan is i mean
we
obviously castle and then maybe we try
to like play
rook a8 and get a and stop you from
uh harassing yes but after that enough
more
hmm
what plan do you have for black beyond
what i just listed
well no it's all good it's like one of
those things it's kind of a hybrid
it feels like a hedgehog and it feels
like a dragon
um so i mean the
the normal thing for white is that he's
got some kind of a c4 b3 the
the disappearance of the a7
and a two pawns uh i think
i think it does favor white because
he can't he could use the the a file
and maybe the b b5 square but
there's no targets in in anybody's
position right like where's the weakness
in white's position
where you know b2 uh e4 where's the
weakness in black's position
e7 it's very hard to get there so it's
i see this is a very hard
play game that it's not easy to to come
up with an effective plan
but having said that it allows for
creative play too
all the pieces are on the board and it's
one of those
positions where the better player
usually wins
and i don't see any easy draws for
either side
i mean i see just hard play ahead
you could be boring here if you want to
do what jen says put a rook on a8
and try to trade off everybody
but careful spidey sense tingling no no
not right now not right yeah yeah i
didn't want to do it
let's castle please yeah i mean yeah
yeah let's castle first
okay castle alert yeah go for putting a
rope on me
uh at some point but we still need to be
careful yes
evil intentions and then he's not even
gonna take a rook he's gonna take the
knight on f6
and then the rock
be very very quiet i'm hunting hunting
rabbit
yeah yeah okay so that's so we can't
actually do that very easily
well you could in this position i i was
trying to induce you to play the move
queen
um to uh back to b8 and then i didn't
know i was maybe
going to put my rook on a3 i was gonna
i don't know if i'm playing for c4 and
rookie three
it's just weird i don't really have a
clear plan
i i would say for for for either side
by the way one game where there is a
really clear situation going on
right now um in i alejandra gate i'm
sorry um verusion gave me
the uh the news yeah the battle of the
sams
on sam jacklin played a really nice move
and moved 14 apparently
um as he hopes to
um go into an even better final position
with the win here he would end with a
plus score um and get his fourth win of
the event and he played the move d3
bar said that's a very nice move um
bishop c5 d takes e4
bishop g6 on the board right right there
was a tactic
if you if black had played the move
e4 takes d3 that was bishop take c6 that
was why bishop c5 was played and
wow you know
i just love i love
big majorities and this is probably one
of the biggest majority
you can get in in english mention bishop
f4 i love that move
there's nothing i i think the best
things
in chess are obviously the checkmate
delivering the checkmate that that's
great
and delivering a series of checks that's
great and delivering a series of
captures all as i really
but also developing with tempo i mean
for me
developing with tempo has always been
the nirvana and i love
this move bishop f4 prepping e5 and it
looks like
but what are you saying as the guy just
won a straight
pawn and he can bully the guy forever
like
exactly it's a straight pawn in your
pocket
thank you i take it last night
and he's gonna kill him by the way when
yes when you said the best things in
chess are
i thought you were going to say free and
i know
that god it cost you a lot
what did it cost sam right now to get
this free pile yeah
no in the words of left polygamy
pain staking effort
now for a very important question is
sam's burt orangeret
but in all seriousness let's go back to
ray robson as i'm hearing there's some
news
on that board a blunder alert
uh well whoa what did we have okay we
left it
okay and we just saw the moon
bishop whoa whoa whoa look at this
tactics maurice you're going to love
this one
was bishop takes check playable
bishop takes e2 was the move according
to
a var and then what's the idea after a
knight c5
you take on maybe you take
f1 okay as well as b3
i mean tactic the position just blowed
up
after the move bishop f8 conversely
after the why was you guys bishop f3
you guys are going too fast wha what
what just happened so he's saying
he told us that bishop f8 was a blunder
by ray
maybe blunder's an overstatement because
i don't think he's losing after bishop
f.a
but bishop takes e2 he said uh we're
informed
was a win because of
bishop takes c4 there i never do
or better for black i'm not sure about
winning right i mean
the body count is two minor pieces for a
rook and then maybe a pawn or two
one well one point you were down upon so
bishop takes b3
and then wait wait just a second jen
because there's a nice
pin on the d file you might want to
throw in 97
or something but okay uh sorry just
uh i did want to throw you off your game
bishop takes
three 97 i can play 97 i can play rook
takes b7 but
but bishop b3
[Music]
i have knight c3 when you're ready also
okay so i understand now what they're
saying they're not saying that this is
that great for black
version is saying rather that lenderman
had a great move after bishop f8 so this
was the best way for black to
keep the balance after bishop f8
um he says
knight to i'm a little confused what
he's saying
um oh 22 bishop f3 he said was not the
right move
and then instead you needed to go knight
to f4
and that was a huge edge for lendermen
okay well keep the pawn in
and keep black's pieces at bay that
makes sense
it's not the it's not the crazy blunder
we would expect some kind of knockout
punch
yeah yeah i'm not a blender alert well i
mean
you know my antenna goes really high
it's like what what
what it reminds me when it reminded me
when i said breaking news
during a broadcast with anish giri you
were there yes
me and you and you and and alejandro
were listening to listening to anish
giri during
during what was his event probably the
magnus carlson maybe no it was a live
event
okay it was a live event we were okay
you were in the studio you and
you guys laughed at me afterwards okay
you and alejandro
and i was and i chimed in that there was
this interesting tactic
but it ended in a draw and it was i had
to stop
ali i had to stop gary who was
extolling the virtues and nuances of his
position
and when i stopped and showed this he
said you stopped
this for a draw like that that's the
breaking news
like seriously go get back to sand so
yeah so then anyway but wait
this one this one is similar to that in
some respects
but sam's game in a way um
speaking of phrase there had been trades
but now sam is up
still just one pawn okay you still have
one pawn
and this is over the guys have a pawn
for no reason
he's up a pawn and also blacks pieces
because he's up upon
our bottled in what are we talking about
the guy just went apart for no reason at
all right
over turn up the pawn on e4 you might be
able to work around it a little bit
but instead it's like a bone in your
throat
yeah i would play f3 myself
with the idea that with the pawn the
extra pawn yes i agree mary's
the extra pawn on f3 is basically
harnessing these two minor pieces the
knight on f6 is ineffective
thanks to the pawn on e4 and the bishop
on g6
is most especially ineffective i ruin
the view of this bishop on g2 and it's
crying it's saying why did you do that
i said because i'm going to put you here
and then the bishop says okay
that's a great relief later after i play
f3 maybe this knight will go to c5 which
is a little bit surprising that sam
therefore
very quickly did play the move knight c3
when i'm sitting there thinking if i
could get my knight to c5 i'm much
more excited knights and recognizing
that this night is not so good sam
sevillan played knight
uh d7 and uh
okay he's upon down
my brain is going like three different
ways because he's down upon
so and it's basically we should lose
this game let's go to
the game between awander liang and el
shawn murray the abadi because
that just got insane and this one
you see the position you're going to see
elshon play this move knight f4
on move 13 uh knight to f4 as you see
the board position right now
if we go ahead the move d4 was played
threatening d5 i'm going to fork you
i'm going to play d5 knight f4
go ahead you want to play d5
make the move and the youngster said i
i'm gonna play d5 and give you this
sacrifice on h3
another capture on h3 and a capture on
f2
hello pieces and two pieces
and then queen to c8
threatening nasties on h3 knight g1
capture back on c6 what is happening
here
knight gf3 pieces
i mean you still have to ju i mean i i
love
uh sacrificing my pieces as much as
anybody else but you gotta justify it
right now this bishop on b2 what did you
how did you describe it maurice because
you did it a very nice way
count the active pieces uh black is down
two pieces the rook on
a and the bishop on b2 are not
not participating right the rook on aa
doesn't
i would say this queen's participating
so
queen g4 is definitely gonna have to
worry about at some point
no doubt about that but can white
beat off the attack with rookie two
that was black's move and black just
like d5
[Music]
okay now we're talking about a position
folks
what is this
why couldn't ray robson and wesley or
daca and wesley be in a position like
this one this is fun for the money
so what's the what's the threat here for
black just the place
i would say e4 is a massive threat
e4 and rookie five and your your king is
toast
one of the other things i'm just looking
at this position
uh jenna and i'm seeing this bishop on
a7
it you know i like to get everybody into
the party and i'm thinking if you could
play
e4 take on d5 play the move c6
bishop b a jack would show up and that
would be like
oh oh boy imagination
i like that oh that would be nice wow
this position is insane how do you
defend it with
white when you have only two pieces over
on that side he just played rook to e2
chasing trying to chase the night but
the night's not going anywhere
well we had the opportunity maybe to
sacrifice to try
to bail out in some situation i mean
you're still gonna have a lot of pieces
hovering over me
but that knight is particularly
dangerous so he might be able to play
like
rook f2 at the right moment okay let's
see the forcing variation right away
it might be right now yeah let's see the
forcing
line e4 i am assuming you're taking yeah
uh unless you can play knight d4 i
didn't think you could
maybe you're asking for it then you have
rookie five
rookie five you told us the threat
telegraph time here comes a rook
i still have rook h5 meeting right so
there's no choice then so you take take
take right so okay i understand rook g1
is on tap i can
let's be sorry back you you went a
little fast there it's very important to
know that rook takes f3
is not playable yes
let's just know that would be for the
audience rook takes
very desirable here you regret the fact
that you have a c3 pawn
right if that c3 bond didn't exist
and suddenly attack the queen takes
threatens rookie two
and no it doesn't threaten rookie two
actually there's no threat
right at the moment well just the same i
think
it's conceivable yeah i i took with the
knight
instantly to avoid that uh variation
i did uh and maybe it was
playable here i'm anticipating
i don't think you well maybe you do want
to take the rook i don't know
uh of course you don't want to play but
you want to
but you but you may have to you have
three connected passers
so and you can take the pawn on d5 and
win material
how about this take the pawn on d5 for
just a moment i know it looks absolutely
ridiculous
and
open up back to this attack but all that
does is provoke king h1 it doesn't right
it doesn't give me the goods rookie 2 on
the board and by the way
would you want to play either side with
only 10 minutes
on the clock i would much rather
be black if i felt like my initiative
was flowing
i would really love to have that f pawn
be sitting on f4 when i'm playing the
movie e4
uh something like that you know some
attacking using this pawn
but at the moment my biggest concern for
black is that rook on a8
because i don't want to see pieces start
liquidating and then i can't
i can't double rooks you know even that
rook we're on e7 right now for example
and i could double rooks and keep the
momentum going but it just feels like
i'm going to run out of steam at some
point if i start taking pieces
how about this as a starting move how
about takes
okay so a moment ago i had my pawn on e4
and you were reluctant to take on d5
because of queen h5 check how about if i
start
with tigs attacking the bishop i'm
hoping to induce the move bishop b5 by
the way
if you played ball five yeah because if
you play
uh ball with me just for a moment i
wanted to play c6
and reintroduce the threat of mate
with my knight covering h1 i do
i do threaten mate now is that the same
if you just take the pawn on on d5
uh yes exactly but in this case i was
also looking at
this because i've got check all right
they're blitzing out moves while we wow
and the computer bar
is flying in one direction
e4 i mean it's just absolutely
okay queen f2 e takes f3
check all on the board yeah and
what was the purpose of this champion
queen into the game
oh and now i'm thinking white is just
completely winning yeah why did he
create his chart
i got three pieces
three pieces for a rook such a good
looking
normally
what is this no wait a minute i mean
nah that's terrible oh three pieces he
got confused maybe thought he was
getting a rover
where he wasn't um something
right yeah because you're right that
that checked something went wrong
that check made things happier for you
um because also after queen not only
that i'm gonna
get a tempo on your queen because you
can't trade obviously
and yeah right queen g5
king h1 and maybe he's maybe he missed
king h1 and thought queen
because there would be a queen d2 check
on the rise i don't know
but um in any case i don't know uh let's
see what happened tonight oh
knight takes it okay i guess
i thought about that too i i kind of
like this move
keep in mind that e2 is protected so
that on a good day we can go rook h1 and
we can
protect our queen but it doesn't happen
with d3 so does it why can't he play
takes on d5
now take on d5 it's still three pieces
brandon let's let's let's come back and
even
and played an even sharper move rook e4
looking at rook g4 check and excuse me
i'm jack
g4 check mark okay that's got my
attention
that queen of three has i like queen of
three with tempo
when you just play but gives the guy a
chance of centralizing the rook
like rook g4 king f1 queen h3
jack you can't step to e2 because i have
g2
i'll try this but
here i i i've got i think the entry
squares covered
uh i'm a little bit scared about
this i'm feeling kind of tied up i don't
know
uh knight takes f3 oh he did play rook
g1 by the way this is the game yeah
we're going over the game
i'm also worried about him just doubling
where's your king hiding
if if the one i can't hide it anyway
double you're going to play king f1 and
i guess check is meant by
queen g2 queen queen g2
stops me no what about rook what about
rookie three sorry
let's not check you let's just try to
disturb your your knight
rookie three uh okay sorry
uh
this oh now you've got queen h1
can't do that if i have to move my
knight i'm not a happy camper i don't
want to move my knight
bishop e2 what am i doing what what is
he doing
uh okay so it means i i can't play king
f1 i have to do
something else um rook e8
okay bishop bishop c1
he took on d5 by bishop c1
doesn't allow the check check i don't
get rook g4 and queen h3
if you play risky bishop c1 that's
that's what i was really aiming for
sure uh taking on d5
does win a tempo but bishop d3 wins the
tempo right back
and i think a wonder
has kind of escaped well not
completely not completely rookie too is
still keeping the pressure look at
foreign
those are three pieces yeah i'm thinking
that rook g3 and maybe bring back
the king to g2 maybe simply bishop
excuse me that was supposed to be bishop
e2 sorry
ideas of c4 and maybe
queen g3 he organ he allowed
white to fix the position and now i'm
seeing c4 in the next move he's put his
work on e8
and now what is i play in g3
queen g3 he's done it queen g3
85 el shawn what was that
dialing with these moves wow
you can't play knight takes uh it's pins
so queenie five okay look at that
rook g22
sorry jen what is that defense game rook
t2 everything on the second rank now
right and with this move with black
you can't break through anywhere there's
nothing that's due to improve the
position
bishop c1 on tap precisely that was
exactly what i wanted to get in is now
c4 is also
a threat isn't it no see yeah c4 c4 was
a threat
oh g5 c4 was
a threat in the last move i can't do it
now i
know bishop f3 guards
the bishop and yes it says
right there regards the bishop so c4
is this is it still oh i wasn't even
thinking
now you have queenie too but oh then you
just have rookie two and i don't have
time to capture your queen because
there's rookie eight
mm-hmm exactly so no i was just looking
at c4 a guy's
just having some fun c4 and if you take
the bishop i wanted to take the rook
but then there's like some weirdness
right one check in rookie two
yeah well now queen e1
no then kingy one rookie two kingy two
exactly
rookie two to kingitsu oh
that's that's winning and check queen
back
uh guys let's take a look at our second
place finishers
ray robson he's struggling and jeffrey
zhang whoa
things have gotten explosive in this
game let me just take
the last two moves and see what has
happened
rookie boom he's trying to play 94 so
the bishop e4
there's uh this is the game between ali
and jeffrey
exactly and then d5
yeah okay i mean this is precarious
are you serious knight e4 is a very bad
move because instead of bishop e4
there's rook takes e4 and what
difference does that make wait a second
so rookie 4d5 now
is why is this so bad because of e7 your
queen
your queen is running out of squares
uh-huh
i'm threatening maybe bishop d6
and if rookie 7 bishop b7 takes on c4
why not take why not take the rook on e7
first of course
i apologize i was going to tell you ah
yeah yeah yeah
that's it that's it and indeed var just
told me that it's exactly the line so
that is what jeffrey must have missed
because
um it's such a funny move it's like
checkmate to the queen
well it's also like you look at bishop
take c7 and now it's like you stop just
one square short of but wait you didn't
check me i mean that wasn't
and luke takes e4 by alejandro because
the line continuing right bishop city
was playable and he's played bishop
before he realized that move was not
that that line was no good i guess
after he played it but the line just
played rookie seven
rook takes bishop d6 rook c7 what was
the next move
you just sacked a row so you just
so now you're trying to win the rook
back is your point
oh you're going to win you're going to
win a second okay
that's what i'm trying to do as well i
know it is
uh he did by the way not go into any of
this after rookie for
jeffrey made a decision i think he's
regretting
oh of course he must have seen it played
i think once happened was once he played
knight before
he realized in horror rookie foreign and
there's the blunder
right it's like the moment you release
the piece is when you suddenly go ah
he has a rook in a pawn for a
bishop and a knight he has a rook in the
pawn for a bishop in the night and you
still have a little bit of work ahead
oh yeah i mean and now queen e3 allows
knight takes b3
and it's played and it's played i mean i
thought queen c2 was forced
now knight b3 her splat and
hello he's gonna get a second pawn for
these two pieces when he plays rook c4
he's gonna be hitting c3
at the same time i mean it just wasn't
that easy yes he might have made a
mistake but jeffrey is just
playing with force on every move now oh
this is not going to be easy we know how
jeffrey zhang fights
meanwhile another player who's going to
need to fight to try to get second
depending on how this game goes is ray
robinson because
he is in trouble i'm hearing against
ray against ella flenderman who's got an
extra pawn
and it's real yeah before these
two pawns uh doubled e pawns weren't
that meaningful now
that white's about to play e5 knight
takes e5 and rook f7
they become very meaningful and f7 f6
was ray's last move hmm
wow i'd almost say this is a grunfeld
but
he's also under a minute left on the
clock yes so
raise a chance it's over here rests on
the ability to save this thing talk
about playing spoiler lenderman
my goodness truly how do you pick the
last day to play your two
finest games games the brilliant bishop
g
the knight f2 maybe i'm not sure about
knight f2 but the brilliant bishop g5
the rook sack on d4
just flipped the script and and end up
jeffrey running to get a draw
and then here against ray winning i mean
we were thinking
well lindemann's not doing that well he
might end up with just zero as the two
second place finishers would go after
him good luck with that
i personally think the game between uh
jeffrey and alejandro is a little bit
more exciting so maybe we should stick
with that one
as it is this is very fascinating in
balance
where we've got two pieces for the rough
but there's also those pawns and
two points are almost even guys a four
minute game with this imbalance
this is definitely just unclear you
might take
the two pieces right obviously it's it's
two pieces
but there's play there's play with five
minutes on the clock the stronger player
uh i i would give you this against me as
either either color
i've always had a soft spot in my heart
for the dragon
palm formation those five pawns uh it
wasn't clear to me
what exactly uh was happening just going
back a moment
if he could have played bishop take c5
why
didn't alejandro take on c5 just clear
the cobwebs from me
i see you're afraid
and i was looking at it and i was hoping
like to put a checkmate on the board
or rookie seven i understand i
understand i understand yeah that would
be me
sure uh let's go back rook e7
and then you're seven queen takes and
i'm downstairs but all dressed down no
we're down
f7 very conveniently perfectly
yes it does okay fair enough fair enough
that was probably
i should have played queen c2 he missed
queen c2 on
this move knight c5 it was time to come
back and
i just checked you got your extra pawn
and it's only one pawn in this case
for your pawn instead of giving the guy
a pawn back just
drop your queen back he played queen e3
which is a weird square to put it on
and just drop the material exactly
now in this position alejandro
still oh he played bishop d5 maybe
angling for
a bishop takes f7 check and a queen e6
check
by the way for the moment give me the
rook
um bishop check queen i've got a feeling
that this game could
easily be decided by the clock yeah i
agree that could be
the decisive factor better better player
in time pressure
that's what it's going to come down to
well we know that jeffrey
um is the better player in time pressure
i mean he's a great boots and rapid
player he's just one of the best in the
world
so no shame in alejandra not being as
good but the pieces could be very scary
to play against in knowing pressure also
because they're the ones that
create mating threats right but right
now jeffrey's not just
speeding some threats of his own because
you know you got to watch out for
a combination of b4 and bishop v4 right
sure but look at that on the a file are
you walking on the ap
bishop b2 or pawn to b4 queen a7
and but bishop b2 resolves the pin but
look at your bishop on a1
and it's like what are you doing with
with this piece your pieces are about to
get
really strange and e6 is going to chase
your
bishop out of d5 as well in this one
i don't know this this is looking good
for black this is looking good for black
white pieces are very poorly coordinated
bishop b3 just played
are there anything like this
i like i like this move a lot because
it's size steps
the variation that you were just talking
about maurice that
e6 would come with the tempo for example
if black cooperates and just drops his
rook back
we could could then transpose into the
line we just looked at where maybe our
bishop isn't
such a target on d5 that's not saying
that i'm excited
for white's position if you do that i
want to put your rook bishop on a1
no question about it i feel like there
should be a tactic here but just work
back to a6 we're certainly
thinking about playing moves like b4
yeah b4 is still a threat where is yeah
so you you still have to probably play
addition people k6 is the money move
guard c6
and b4 is still a threat after rook a6
so bishop b2 okay you need to play
bishop b2 and solve
all i you know resolve the the i would
talk i would hate to play bishop
i would not play bishop b2 i would play
knight c2
i would play knight c2 with the dream of
moving my rook
and then moving my bishop now of course
you can force me
to trade uh rooks nah this is not good i
i think black is better
black is simply better yeah i mean ever
since
rook a4 alejandra has been suffering
because it's going to be hard to
coordinate his miners and that's how you
play when you've got the miners against
the majors
i think he did play
yeah but i think this was a crucial
moment alejandro didn't appreciate
that this was actually a big threat this
was just a big time threat
you had to you you have to play with as
many pieces on the board as you can
as black as white i beg your pardon and
just to
stop the tactics you guys have been
talking about which is b5b4
this move bishop d5 was really helpful
to
um uh to black
and now alejandra is suffering
he played e6 to blunt the effect of the
bishop
oh that's a relief that's a real move i
mean
yeah i just i gaze thank you i can
breathe
i can breathe again uh i will boom my
rook i'm not sure where
i think d1
don't breathe too long because you only
got a minute left on the clock i don't
have much time i understand
but now the game between a wander leong
he did defeat el shawn so
nice finish for the youngster who
started off 03.
wow tip your hat to a wonder for that
remarkable comeback because you're right
when you
when you're 03 everybody
is looking at you and saying you're my
point in the tournament
oh nice nice uh is this that
bishop d3 yeah elshon
alshon just i mean he just he had his
moment there
in this game uh oh yes i i just don't
like the way he played it let's
go back to the game of jeffrey zhang as
the players are
well they are moving fast takes takes
rook jeffrey gave jeffrey gave alejandro
a break and now alejandro's pieces
are sprightly remember that bishop that
was on a3 might have been on a1
it's now sitting on f4 it could
potentially go to g5
uh cause some issues the double rooks
right now
i'd i would stop a nice move knight a
three stopping any kind of doubt that
was important i missed reading pieces
his knight will fly into the game and
white
why what white's going to play for
something here a guy he's going to play
jeffrey is a draw here is huge for him
and that just left him
you know something like five grand right
because um
ray looks like he's busted and that
means eight points would give jeffrey
jean clear second i don't think he knows
that
because he's engrossed in this game and
with rey in such great form he has
no reason to think that ray would be
losing but
that's the reality he can get clear
second with jester draw
well good luck with that because there's
a long way to go the temporary
and this position is very dangerous for
him oh yeah ray robinson's position
is looking the race don't raise just
that's gone
only six seconds left on the clock
jeffrey i'm much more optimistic about
his ability to draw because he's also
playing against alejandro
who's gonna be on increment quite soon
guys and uh
150 seconds left at the moment i mean
raising
dead busted any way you can count it
there's no
there's no hope in this position it's
just he's
he's going to lose he's just going to
lose we can show the game side by side
guys because
yeah uh let's leave it let's leave ray's
game on your board he has
and the other game the alejandra and
it's critical because ray's gone the
live game
yeah bray's dead so let's the live game
go to
to this one and let's see he did manage
to get a pair of
rooks off the board that's good for
black
i don't know what happened what just
happened that caused that
black is happy to see rooks leave the
board white
should have kept a pair of rooks on at
all costs somehow the trade occurred
and this position is much harder for him
to
to win oh no the other route forgets
about he just blunted a piece
oh my god and he saw it
he sure did is the poker face is off
and alejandra when it rains it pours
this game it looks like
it rains it pours you do you don't trade
rooks
you you just don't and now look at that
jeffrey has assured himself
at least a tie per second alejandro
despondent as ever
but it looks like actually reyes is
going to end up sorry
yeah rey's going to end up going down in
this game his best
best of hope is a draw jeffrey jean with
another second place finish
he's in his second in the juniors and he
finished second here
amazing performance amazing month for
him he might be is he the big money
winner
um i think that 40k will still be higher
because the junior
championship yeah 25 was was not as high
um although it's funny yeah if you won
the scholarship and the 6000 top prize
it would be
very very close it would have been a
nice uh very nice month oh he ran
a few grand shy but um in fact um john
burke did get the 6k
prize and scholarship but hey jeffrey um
has had a real
uh tremendous season i mean he even gave
ms carlson a hard time which uh it gives
us an indication of
of how of how great he is and um his
future
so jesus played by lenderman jeffrey is
turning 20 tomorrow this is a good
birthday present coming in
clear second in the u.s championship and
playing
great chess he took wesley all the way
to that finish line
just a little bit of extra time in his
clock he would have he would have drawn
that game
but let me tell you something guys three
years from now two to three years from
now
i'm seeing jeffrey at the 27
55 27 70 range i mean
he's sky's the sky is bright
uh as far as he's concerned his
prospects are great
it has been wonderful over the years of
visiting
st louis chess club and watching jeffrey
uh grow up essentially going from
success to success
how many championships have just jeffrey
played in saint louis
i'm going to just throw out like five
five probably five six
yeah yeah and we saw him as a really
young junior
as a wife thank you yeah yeah one year
maybe one the junior to get in and i was
just getting it
yeah and now we see him as a very mature
young man
uh well
yeah he can fight and punch with the
best of them he just needs
a little just maybe a little bit more i
was going to say
it's all about opportunities when i was
young
coming up there was just not that many
opportunities in the united states
all the good events were literally
overseas
mainly europe russia or soviet union if
you will
but now it's really universal and we see
a lot of top chests being played for
example uh in asia china
uh is really coming up so um
just more opportunities give you know
give him those category 20 events or
whatever
it is sam's game is very interesting i
mean you could keep this one up maybe on
your analysis board if you want to see
what happens but um you know ray is not
going to win this and that would be the
only way no
way is now ray's not winning he'll get
third place um but the battle of the
sams is kind of fun
uh i see a pawn on c2 it's wild um 30
seconds for the stamp set
wait wait was it wasn't sam just up a
clean pawn
winning with no problem before yeah so
obviously he was
fine well for him we don't know how that
happened but looking at the position
right now he just played a rook to b6
check
so what's the deal here guys do we have
to take that pawn
rook c6 what happens if rook c6
i don't know that bishop looks like a
funny rook c6 hangs your bishop doesn't
it i
start attacking it maybe i mean i i can
always go bishop c2 knight c2 and play
king h5
right and oh sure well yeah well you
know but then you have rookie three
check and it should be a draw
and and so we did try work seasick
ray's game is over ray has lost he has
but he still gets clear third but a nice
pickup for alex who will move up in the
standings
great results for alex when you scored
one and a half out of two
against ray and jeffrey that's the kind
of way you want to finish your
tournament
you you might have had a bad tournament
but you finished with one and a half out
of two in the last two days especially
when you're in your last wrong game we
all know that feeling you win your last
round game you leave the tournament with
a good memory
right and as well as greater tournament
as ray had
that's going to be a better taste in his
mouth to leave the tournament with the
loss
definitely great results at third but
he's he's not going to be happy
losing the last round game anyway this
game this is what i was saying you put
your rook on c6
i can force you to either move your
bishop or play bishop c2
no i'm going to play he played rook
takes c2 and
i i can take this pawn when i want make
a draw
but man uh sam shanklin is wondering
how did i let this guy slip away oh
absolutely terrible absolutely
no way in the world he should have not
won this game
a clean pawn up and now hurrying up to
just clean up the board so that he can
get this draw
that's crazy exactly exactly
wow i was going to say that
for uh alex lenderman i mean he's kind
of just waking up
saying why is the tournament over why
isn't this a double round robin i mean
guys i've played myself into form i'm
really happy about uh
what i just did and what did sam just do
he played
rook f2 doesn't everybody just play rook
check and take a pawn here
like what what is going on
okay that's uh that was strange for me
very strange oh well his 11 seconds
tells the reason
he's he's missing moves at this moment
as he is at a struggle to find
best moves right now but it is it is
kind of funny because this knight on g2
is stupid right we all agree
obviously but the crazy part is it
does fulfill the purpose it does attack
the square
h4 so it just happens to give the rook
this opportunity to go after the h2 pawn
and now uh well if i can take it off and
not
lose a king and pawn end game that's
what i'm doing
don't touch that pawn be careful well
he's done it
yeah no he's keeping the rook though
he's doing it well isn't this no isn't
this just
easy drawing oh king e6 uh yeah we have
six is possible he did it you're right
he did it he did it
yeah because white's king can't stay on
the fourth rank the key move is king e5
exactly got the opposition yes and there
it is a draw
in this game and look at sam
disappointed but that means that lanier
dominguez who had a very rough start in
this event
ends in clear fourth with wow wow
so we weren't paying much attention but
he did have something of a comeback guys
because he wasn't
in the running for the top spots but uh
when you're a nice finish
as we'll um prepare those standings for
you
but you know big congrats to our
champion wesley so what a stunning
performance
jeffrey clear second and let's take a
look at
alejandro's reaction when he blundered
after
against jefferson oh my god that is one
for
the uh the real guys the expression real
it's not how you want to close a
tournament that is just not
you could have jeffrey zhang in your
hand and
instead you blunder a piece that is not
how you want to remember the torment
not not at all
well guys i have to say this has been an
incredibly eventful october
it felt like um all of these
championships somehow
built ourselves up for this event and
this event delivered
and just a big congratulations to wesley
so i mean
that tpr you know like you say maurice
you get your name mentioned with bobby
fischer where the chess world is
concerned
you did something very special it has
been a very special event it's been
it's been great games that he would be
proud to play that anyone would be proud
to play
in a classical tournament or something
leslie so played here
um but we have our third place finisher
graham master ray robson who delighted
us throughout the event
hey ray um congrats on finishing third i
know it was a tough
last round loss but you did have a
tremendous performance here
hi ren i don't know if he hears us quite
yet
ray ray's not here
to turn on his hi ray who are you with
us
hi how are you guys hi
so you ended up finishing third in the
tournament you know you delighted us
with so many entertaining games what do
you think the most
memorable part of this event was for you
um yeah i don't know i had i think
maybe besides today all the other days i
think i played
um some really interesting games um
i thought the first day i probably
played the best i think against
both the wonder and against sam i
basically didn't make any mistakes
um so probably those games i mean the
game
yesterday against sacara was was crazy
like i did a very unusual p
sacrifice and that was just a wild game
um
yeah i don't know there were there were
tons of interesting games i'm not sure
if there's one that particularly stands
out but i was just happy the way i
played the first
two or three days especially so you had
a tough order
today in your opening round of the day
against
wesley so you needed to play all out for
a win but he's so solid
can you give some insight into
preparation and that big moment
yeah it's tough against wesley um
like he's playing the most sound opening
in
chess history and he knows every single
line so i mean you have a choice either
to try to
either you have to come up with
something really new which obviously i
mean
people who are better than me have
already tried to do that and usually
failed um and or you
hope he he maybe doesn't know something
in the opening or forget something or
you can just try to avoid theory and
just play like an equal position and
just try to outplay him but
problem with that is when he gets a
comfortable position he's
i think that's where he really excels
like he usually doesn't make mistakes in
those positions and he often
outplays his opponent so um i decided to
play something
somewhat theoretical of which i hoped
wouldn't be his main focus because i
played c3 in this
game of move five which i usually don't
play um
but he was obviously prepared i mean
normally he castles there but he played
d5 maybe for the first time ever and uh
yeah he obviously knew everything um and
yeah i just had to go for the main line
um which we followed and
um i could have tried to put more
pressure but i'm sure he he had
everything
planned so yeah move um
19
king b2 rook fda so yeah i i wasn't
really expecting him to go for this so i
didn't
um really know this very well but
instead of rook hd1 i think rook takes
e5 was
probably the most critical and then i
think black's supposed to play rook
takes c3
um because if king takes there's a fork
on d4
so instead i can play rook d1
um rook c c8
rook takes d8 or takes d8 rookie seven
and at first it looks like
um i mean either black has to be very
passive with rook b8 or black takes f2 i
take b7 and i have this majority on the
queen side which looks dangerous but
here
black has a bishop d4 check
king b3 and b5 which is very strong i
think b5
more or less neutralizes white's
initiative um
so yeah i didn't remember this during
the game i remember there was some idea
like this where black has to find a very
precise move
um so i would have tried this if i
remembered but
i'm sure he he probably knew this b5
move i'm sure so
it was yeah after that after rook d1e4 i
think there's just
like zero chances against wesley
well it was really so much fun watching
our games right we
especially um as you mentioned some of
those games where everything was
completely explosive who will forget
that time scramble against sam
stevian oh i forgot about that yeah
you're right like the end of that game
was
crazy like that's one of the most
interesting
positions like that i've seen occur in
like a real game
um especially with that situation where
we both had no time yet maybe that was
the most memorable um
because at the end where his king was
was running up but then he's
i'm queening i'm up like two rooks or
something but he's trying to mate me
yeah that was crazy
exactly well ray it was so thank you and
it was certainly a
memorable event that we have for your
game so
thank you and good luck in your future
thanks guys then um bye
bye bye
and wasn't that uh i mean mr excitement
ray robson like you say a little
disappointing going down in that very
final game but boy
i mean so many so many games in this
tournament that he played just
incredibly
we've got jx in the building
with a second place finish
congratulations jeffrey
first of all this last game was
completely
wild you you must have felt some danger
here but you managed to get it done
yeah thank you um yeah i uh
completely blundered this one
detail um when i played knight e4
i i saw rook takes e4 and i was planning
um
i was planning d5 rookie 7 rookie 7 but
i just forgot he can play bishop d6 here
and it's probably just over
so yeah i tried something else and
fortunately he blundered relatively
quickly he blundered the
pawn on b3 so after that i was back in
it
and um i thought actually
my position was fine apparently i'm
still worse but i thought
with rook and two pawns it should be
good chances for me
and then later he did give you a chance
at the time pressure
to get these tricks off when you were
able to do it
did you come into today feeling any of
the after effects of yesterday's loss to
wesley
what was your aim main aim for today
yeah i mean i definitely wanted to try
and
put pressure on wesley still um in the
the first game
i think i just got a little bit careless
um i thought
i had a pretty good position around here
uh after he took on f2 i think we both
blundered um
some tactics i could have just taken on
a6
i think i was worried about knight d3
but um
should there should be a way for for me
to to be on top
but uh what i chose in the game i also
thought was good but then
he found this nice um counter shot with
bishop g5 and rook d4
what did you think when this move landed
on the board did you see it coming
because no not at all from alien chess
yeah it was it was kind of alien chess
um
yeah i thought he had to you know move
the knight or play e5 and
the complications would work out for me
but after bishop g5 is just
liquidating into uh into a
josh bishop ending what was your mindset
by the way when you saw the move on the
board would you
did you think oh my god what the heck is
that you spent some time on the move
um well i realized right away i mean it
was probably
gonna force this position and once
um basically i couldn't get out of the
pin so
yeah i just understood that uh probably
i had
had ruined the position
you had a small nuance i was wondering
why you didn't move the rook away
and take the pawn on b7 it seemed like
that would have given you some chance to
play a little bit
uh you you played rook c2 instead why
didn't you
go for the ending
uh yeah that's a good question probably
it was definitely a better try to at
least
at least hope for something i i think i
probably didn't like
this position in general maybe but yeah
i completely agree that
that uh the tournament situation
likely required me to try this approach
your second place finish obviously is a
fantastic finish you have a score that
normally would win a tournament like
this one what is your feeling about your
month
you came in a very close second in the
juniors
and now hear a clear second in the
in this open uh yeah it's
it's definitely a bit disappointing um
to come up short in both
events uh but nonetheless i'm really
happy with
with the way i fought um in both
tournaments and
played a lot of great games um but yeah
just
a few decisions that i i might like to
have back
gonna celebrate tomorrow turn the big
2-0
or an old man tomorrow yeah yeah i'm
getting older um yeah we'll see we'll
see what
what uh what what i can what
plans i might i might have
well you do have an additional 28
thousand dollars
in your pocket this month congrats on
that winning 25 here and
of course was it three or four in the
junior make it four in the junior show
29 000 so could
good pay month congratulations
we expect to see many of these
performances and maybe a little bit
better next time in 2021.
congrats and we'll see you soon and
happy birthday
happy birthday jeffrey thank you very
much
thank you jeffrey for all your great
play keep it up
great result hey if he does better than
eight half out of 11 guys
i i'll say i got my money on jeffrey 9
out of 11. was actually
leslie sews four but eight and a half a
scorching result as well
usually enough to win clear first i
would say i would say
sign jeffrey up for eight and a half out
of 11 every year
for the next 10 years i'll take i'll
take this result
exactly let's take a look at these
numbers
eight wins in a row two
wins back to back and rate round eight
and nine when he needed them the most to
clinch himself
that's a result sparkling a beautiful
final day
um he had very little chance um
to lose a title i mean he was in total
control
here he is our champion wesley hi
everyone yeah yeah thank you champ is
here
wesley your second second championship
how does it feel
yeah it feels really great this really
means a lot to me having the title of
the us champion
is so big uh i mean when i first went
2017
i really wanted to win the first time
but then
uh after that i had a bit of a slump my
rating has gone down
and uh i thought
it's really difficult to win it a second
time and uh
i was having already summed up whether i
was going to
so winning a second title is really it's
really big to me i'm very happy to
have won it this this title is really
prestigious
so uh so yeah next year hopefully we'll
go back to
over the board i know that playing
online is not ideal
and uh but hopefully next year things
will be better with
the current buyers plan hopefully
wesley you had a result that had not
been seen
in the u.s championship in 50-plus years
uh in fact since 1966 probably
officially scoring
nine and a half your your score is the
same
score as fisher
all the way back then it makes your
score the third best score in history
nobody other than bobby fischer has
matched
this line score of nine points out of
11 games what does that mean to you to
know that it's only you and fisher with
this number
in a u.s championship 11-round
invitation
oh well yeah yeah it means a lot uh
the most important to win the title but
uh
i don't think you can really compare
anybody to fisher i have
high respect for him he's
one of the greatest chess players who
ever lived
um so yeah to score
nine points out of 11 if it's really a
big deal
i obviously needed a bit of a lot
nowadays
to try to to get that score
but uh yeah i wasn't expecting it i
thought
eight and a half out of 11 would be good
enough for for for first place as i said
two days ago
um and my start hasn't been very good
also the positions i'm getting
um probably the secret is just to take
it one game
one day at a time one game at a time and
try to get the chances if uh if your
opponent gives it to you
but uh yeah i don't think i'll be ever
i'll be able to repeat this this this
score again
it's uh indeed
epic score what do you have to say about
the play of young jeffrey zhang
and ray robson in this event they really
chased you down
yeah i know ray robson and yeah i think
ray robson played the
almost the tournament of his life really
uh he's been so aggressive
he's been so good even with very little
time
and uh yeah he's played super well in
this
in this tournament especially with when
he gets aggressive
attacking positions so
yeah this is definitely one of the best
tournaments ever
and uh jeffrey is improving
very quickly it's uh he's an amazing
young player
i know he works a lot in this chest and
uh and happy birthday to him by the way
i just
remember his birthday so uh
jeffrey's uh the
bright star right now if he has uh
i thought when he reached 2700 i thought
he would slow down for a bit you know
but
even maintaining a rating 2700 is not so
easy
but it seems like he's ready to move on
to the next step
and i know he works with uh maybe a
coach or two he works regularly on his
chest
so he's played well in the last couple
of online tournaments that he's been
in and he's he's improving
every day so i'm um very excited and
and i'd like to congratulate him
as well i'm actually a bit surprised he
didn't win the the us junior
i mean if you can score eight and a half
out of
in the uf championship and he only
scored seven out of
nine four six and a half out of nine the
u.s junior
that seemed like i just i just thought
he'd win the u.s junior easily
but those kids are strong
those kids those kids are tough finally
yeah
actually yeah it's funny because uh
i was watching the us junior and uh yeah
i'm
surprised that jeffrey's not crushing it
there but then i played
next day brandon jacobs on chess.com
and uh and they're fast
yeah they're fast they're fast and
furious they're kids
they can spot them but uh
i'd like to say one thing i'd just like
to thank peter also for his
gentlemanship and sportsmanship in the
last game obviously he could
still have spoiled my tournament but uh
i was very nervous actually today so
i knew that two girls are probably gonna
cut it but
i thought hiker would go for the some
crazy stuff like the dutch or the king's
indian
and i prepared some solid lines there
but
we'll just play his normal openings
because we played
the the same opening two years ago
i think i debated with king hd i'm on 26
but
but yeah just like to thank him for
allowing me to celebrate early
wesley just my last question for you is
this
this event took place online a u.s
championship
like we have never seen what do you feel
about the fact that it was organized
anyway and a 40 000
check you take home for this rapid event
you couldn't imagine given given that we
we couldn't play in person that the
purse would still be this amazing
and you'd be able to win the title and
pocket a good chunk of change
yeah it's incredible and it's yeah i'd
like to
thank our sponsors of course i mean
mostly rex and gina singh field
for being so generous to chess and also
i'd like to thank
the usgs federation and
the people who made this event possible
uh chris bird
uh the arbiters for doing great job like
to thank uh tony rich and enjoy brave
for
working behind the scenes making this
all possible i'd like to thank kevin
duggan and q daily and also i'd like to
thank you guys for
doing such a tremendous uh show and
giving entertainment to thousands of
people
and i watch your commentaries right
right after the game
every day but uh but yeah i mean it's
incredible because
uh you know this year's call video uh
i think chess has become more popular
online but
if you don't have sponsors of perks and
genie there would be really no money
probably chess players will be fighting
for
one thousand or two thousand dollars
here and there uh
but the amount of money that they're
putting on chess is uh
is really incredible allows
it allows uh chess players to make a
living and i think
eating car just it encourages younger
people to to spend their time studying
just
if uh if not for if not for them i'd
probably be working in a grocery or
something
no way wesley we know you're an
unbelievable talent a great genius you
make our job easy
thank you so much for your gentlemen
your
gentlemanly behavior as well your class
act as well as
your brilliant play congratulations once
again you are the 2020
u.s chess champion we'll see you at the
closing ceremony
okay thank you leslie
and congratulations it is forty thousand
dollars our 2020
u.s chess champion wesley so
wow what a tournament he had i never
would have bet
that anybody would get nine out of 11
and nearly uh 23 000 tpr fantastic and
there is our closing ceremony again
five o'clock central time that's six
o'clock in the east coast you can watch
it on twitch or
youtube ustestcamps.com we're going to
have a combined channel ready for
all five events so you will hear from
carissa gibb
john burke joel benjamin irina crash and
leslie cell
incredible guys five championships in
one month
i only did four of them i was busy for
the first one you guys did
five congratulations work
person-like if i'm gonna be politically
correct
but you guys got it done it's always a
pleasure
these four were such a pleasure to work
with you too as
always it's online or not it's just
great to
to see it to see us the gangs all
together
let's count them down our contestants
jen
that's right well we had 12 tremendous
competitors
el shawn morata body tied for eleventh
but he started out
with so much solidity he got here
from the us open and take home over four
thousand dollars
and he tied with he's like with
grandmaster alejandro ramirez
as we're used to having him on the
commentary side he's also the coach at
slu but hey he can pick him up and put
him down
as well and he gave the runner-up for a
run for his money in that last round
um and ends up tied for 11th as well
and then we have our 10th place finisher
darius
um with over 5 000 dollars honestly he
played a lot of interesting games
combative openings special akash
broomfelds i'm sure he would have liked
to have even more points
but he sure did keep us in her pain when
we got a chance to see his games
he certainly did the slew student as
well
and then we had grandmaster alex
lenderman what a
finish this young man had he gets ninth
play for over 6k
but he changed the destination event um
he
held a draw in a very difficult game
against jeffrey john
which chat with kep zhang just a step
behind
wesley cell it's a very inspired play
from lenderman he also
won against our bronze finisher in the
last round he kuro nakamura a
pre-tournament favorite
perhaps the pre-tournament favorite um
ended in a tie for seventh
not something that he will be pleased
with but honestly i mean he's had such
an incredible
year guys that you've got to expect that
there are going to be some setbacks and
this was one for
ricardo definitely a big big setback for
hikaru because he
prides himself on his u.s championship
performance as the first time
in his history as maurice mentioned that
he had a negative score and sam savion
uh agenda well grand master sam savion
got off to a great start um
and he ends up with time for sevens and
over 7k
in earnings and yeah one of the most
memorable games of the event for me
was his time scramble with robson which
could have gone anyway
and robson did end up getting the point
but
a battle like that requires two
performers i'll tell you that
and i will remember sam's performance
here and in the junior
um for a long time uh defibrillator
alert for that game absolutely
amazing grandmaster sam shanklin takes
home
ten thousand dollars i know he would
have won it even a little more
as he was winning in his final game but
he had some great games as well
three wins in a row at some point in the
tournament and also has the honor of
saying that when he did lose it was
usually some kind of brilliancy
so if he wasn't on the wrong end of
those who knows
how many points he would have gotten
missed opportunities for sam
and wander leong also tied for fifth now
this is one for the kids at home for
anyone at home not just the kids
to be inspired because this young man
started with three
losses and he ends at the top half of
the cross table
with 10k in the bag that is
a very inspiring tale of resilience
how do you do it a wonder fantastic well
done on your finish
liner dominguez also had a slow start
and he ended up in fourth place
for 13 000 great comeback from dominguez
a little disappointing for lanier i'm
sure he felt that he would like to have
been
more let's say combative for the first
place
and there ray robson wow talk about
fireworks man
grandmaster ray robson played some of
the most entertaining tests we've seen
all october
and that's saying something yes sir it
is it is
but you're right i mean it was just
fantastic
watching him every day it was inspiring
and ray performed
boy did he ever it was great yep he got
into tie pressure but he knew how to
behave
when he got there and what do you say
jeffrey jung
tremendous result eight and a half
points
25 000 great games great
great play in all the different stages
great technique
but you know there's was somebody in
this tournament
who was in even better form and in a way
that's
that's just bad luck for jeffrey because
this could have been his title
but he'll come back with a lot of great
memories and games
and here he is our champ grandmaster
wesley
sell first place 40 thousand dollars and
the title and we saw from our interview
with wesley after the game
that title is very important to him he
ties for a record with
none other than bobby fischer in terms
of his impressive
9 out of 11. and just to his composure
in this event
something that and it's kind words for
his opponents that's something you
always hear from wesley
you know he doesn't he doesn't just say
yeah those guys played well good job
he he gave he gave some very specific
like yearbook-like quotes for his some
runner-ups
um love to see it and love to see wesley
so smile
at the end of a successful championship
campaign
yeah he appraised ray's performance as
the tournament of his life
and for me wesley sews game
against jeffrey zhang was just a
phenomenal game in a game
really worthy of deciding the
championship
and jeffrey gave wesley everything
i mean just a great great game and
wesley was just
that much more determined it's very hard
to say it but
you know that's a that was an amazing
amazing game thank you to both those
players and to everybody
for competing in this great tournament
maurice yes it was the differentiating
factor it was the one game that
separated them
in the event if they had drawn that game
they'd be tied gone another way
but jeffrey would have won the
tournament so
and just enthralling the whole
tournament was tremendous
i loved it and of course the four days
the four tournaments we did together
were tremendous as well
so it's finally over it's finally over i
just want to give one
other note of thanks to ed gonzalez for
giving us
all those great nuggets about u.s
championships past
uh that certainly bolstered a lot of our
data as we get from ed he's the one
who's the biggest fan he never misses
one of these
he takes time off for work you talk
about his job at the post office
jen he takes time off for work because
he loves this event so much
and who wouldn't this is our favorite
one
and it just keeps on giving and giving
and giving the gift that keeps on giving
well it's well like the usps it delivers
maury uh thank you sure did deliver
um and yeah shout out to yasser and var
thank you of course the version as well
for all of his great insights
and among his great insights we're
predicting correctly
the tournament champion along with
yoster ceremony
very good and again i'd just like to say
a big big shout out thank you so much
to the st louis chess club the sing
phil's i
know everybody's got to get ready for
the
closing ceremonies so we'll see you
all there that'll start at five right
jen that's pie central
time indeed and we'll be thanking
everyone there but yeah huge shout out
to everyone to aaron marcus
with her v chess to kevin to kitay
um of course to tom our director making
us look good
and to koshikawski who does recap videos
on our st
louis tesla youtube channel um what a
what a tremendous team
that we have here um and thank you one
and all
yeah and of course to our audience um
you know you guys inspire us and we
thank you for
watching this show um day after day and
hope you
enjoyed every minute of it and there's
more to come
as the closing ceremony will start in
just a little over an hour guys
absolutely well thank you everyone and
have a very good night
thank you see you the closest ceremony
[Music]
you